THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING WILL COME
TO ORDER I THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR- HE SENDS WE ARE GOING
TO BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WE
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE A CORN
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE- PRESENTING-
BILLS I KNOW CENTERPIECE YOU'RE
ABOUT TO GO PRESENT A BILL
THANK YOU FOR. HELPING US GET
THIS STARTED. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT. THE PUBLIC- LET'S DO
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT- SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. THERE WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW THE
PARTICIPANT PHONE NUMBER IS.
877-336-4437 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT TWO SIX. EIGHT
FOUR TWO EIGHT. BY THEIR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON OUR
WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN
ZERO. FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOUR LINE NUMBER. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'RE WAITING QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK- WE REQUEST
THAT YOU MUTE THE DEVICE ON
WHICH YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING- PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY- I MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED- WE MAKE
EVERY EFFORT TO HAVE THIS RUN
SMOOTHLY SOMETIMES THE
TECHNOLOGY. DOES NOT COOPERATE
AND WE WILL DO OUR- VERY BEST-
AS I MENTIONED- I AM. CURRENTLY
I WAS THE ONLY MEMBER PRESENT
WE NOW HAVE TWO OF S WELCOME
CENTER- WE'LL BEGIN- AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND THEN AS SOON AS
WE HAVE- FIVE MEMBERS HERE WILL
STOP US WARM SO WE'LL BE
HEARING BILLS NOW BUT UNTIL WE
GET A QUORUM WE OBVIOUSLY CAN'T
VOTE- ELEVEN BILLS ON THE
AGENDA WHICH WILL BE HEARD ON
FILE ORDER. I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT ITEM NUMBER TWELVE- MAYBE
TEN FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRIAN- HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE AGENDA AT THE
AUTHOR'S REQUEST WE WILL HEAR
THAT ITEM NEXT WEEK SO THAT
WILL BE HEARD BUT NOT TODAY-
SO. LET'S SEE. I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
ON OUR CONSENT. CALENDAR THEIR
ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY THREE
FORTY FIVE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
FORCE FORTY SEVEN THAT ITEM
NUMBER. SEVEN EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN- WE WILL NOW BEGIN
PRESENTATIONS- WE'RE GONNA
TAKE- OUT OF ORDER ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRACE AND I
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU
FOR AGREEING TO THAT A REVERSAL
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
YOU MAY PRESENT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN SENATOR. I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT A B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR WHICH WILL ALLOW QUALIFIED
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS TO
EFFECTIVELY STREAMLINE- HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AS INTENDED UNDER
CURRENT LAW SB THIRTY FIVE WAS
A LANDMARK EFFORT TO INCREASE
OUR HOUSING SUPPLY. BY
STREAMLINING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR HOUSING PROJECTS IN
LOCALITIES THAT ARE FAILING TO
MEET THEIR RINA GOALS AB ELEVEN
SEVEN FOUR MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO ADDRESS THESE
EMERGENT ISSUES FIRST TO
CLARIFY IS THAT THE THREE YEAR
SHOT CLOCK FOR DEVELOPMENT. AND
MODIFICATIONS APPROVAL IS
POSSIBLE TO CITIES TO THE
PROJECT'S SECOND IT SPECIFIES
THAT A PROJECT MUST ONLY
COMPLIED WITH THE OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS THAT WERE IN PLACE
WHEN THE PROJECT WAS INITIALLY
APPROVED. AND THIRD IT
SPECIFIES THAT CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITY ON THE SITE MUST HAVE
BEGUN FOR A PROJECT APPROVAL TO
REMAIN VALID WITH THESE CHANGES
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WILL
INSURE THE QUALIFYING HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS CAN BE
EFFECTIVELY STREAMLINED AS
INTENDED. BY WITNESSES MICHAEL
LANE WAS FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WHEN I GO TO THE LEAD
OUR WITNESSES SAY YOU ONLY HAVE
ONE LAY WITNESS CORRECT. SO YOU
TECHNICALLY HAVE FOUR MINUTES
BUT YOU ABSOLUTELY DO NOT HAVE
TO TAKE THE FULL FOUR MINUTES-
YOU MAY PERCEIVE. THANK YOU MR
TROUBLE VERY QUICKLY BY PLANE.
RESEARCH STUDIED. PUBLIC POLICY
THINK TANK. IT SOUNDS LIKE WE
HAVE A CONNECTION AT THIRTY
FIVE. THIRTY THIRTY FIVE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. THE COMMITTEE BY THE
PROFESSIONAL PORTABLE HOUSING
BUBBLES UP. HOME BEHIND WORK
PRETTY. BUT STATION IS IT. NOT
MOMENT OF BAND IN BUT- IT
DIDN'T CATCH THE NAME LET THAT.
LET IT PROTECT IT I MEAN BY
BOTH. I THANK YOU VERY MR LINE
WE WILL NOW TO- WE WHICH ROOM
NUMBER TWO WE TODAY A TWENTY.
ONE TWELVE WHEN I GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE I SEE FIRST OF ALL I
SEE NO ONE- IN THE GALLERY WHO
WISHES TO GET PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS BILL. WHEN I GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE SEEING THE ONE ROOM
ONE TWELVE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE-
QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT. PRESS BE.
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF. BECAUSE THE PART
OF EIGHTY ONE ONE SEVEN. ONE OF
THE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
IT'S PART OF. ONE SEVEN FOUR AT
FIND OUT. THE BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER. THANK. HEARING THE
EXPERT. UNDER NO THIRD- IN
SUPPORT OF THE. ONE SIXTY ONE.
SO THIS IS. REMEMBERED OKAY.
OUR ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS- CALIFORNIA DMV.
AND NO PROPERTY COMPANY. FOR
AND THE GREENBELT ALLIANCE OKAY
THANK YOU PAT I APOLOGIZE WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO TAKE A PAUSE
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH EIGHTEEN
T. SYSTEM IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO
BE REBOOTED- AND- ACTUALLY THIS.
WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO CALL BACK
AT. IT. WHAT PEOPLE NEED. OKAY
RIGHT WE DON'T THINK PEOPLE
WILL HAVE TO CALL BACK AND WE
APOLOGIZE IF YOU'RE
DISCONNECTED JUST CALL BACK
AND- SHORTLY IF YOU ARE AND I
APOLOGIZE TO THE PUBLIC FOR
THIS TECHNICAL PROBLEM WE'RE
GONNA REBOOT THE SYSTEM SO
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE
FOR AT&T TO REBOOT.
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IF
ANY AND THE FACT OF YOUR
SUPPORT. RIGHT SO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
HAVE NOT ALREADY QUEUED UP.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO IT BY
PRESSING ONE END ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR ONE
SIXTY ONE WILL OPEN UP YOUR
LIFE. OKAY WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR LINE SIXTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
NINE MINUTES KELLY COLIN I AM
FROM THE ORIGINAL POINT CO
SPONSORED AB LEVINSON REPORTING
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RESEARCHER THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING FUEL SOUTHERN
COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF A B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. ONE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN-
GOOD- GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AGAIN WILLIAM BUT THE
BIRD ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
AN AVIATION CALIFORNIA YIMBY.
HER AND GREENBELT ALLIANCE
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. BEFORE
WE OPEN MY TWENTY FOUR DUE TO
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES REPORT
WHAT WILL REPEAT AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHY TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. MY TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT REMINDED
ME TO WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
AND WITH NO RESPONSE WILL
RELEASE THE LINE YET NO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO
WE WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION.
TO AB. ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WE
HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
IDENTIFIED. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE SENATE
GALLERY. SEEING NINE WILL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. I SEE NO ONE
THERE WOULD NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR-
PLEASE- GIVE UP NOW AND STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY
AND THE FACT OF YOUR OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION- PLEASE
CONTINUE. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- SENATOR TROUBLE
GETTING COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
THAT'S OKAY- AGAIN WE HAVE NOT
YET ESTABLISHED REQUIREMENTS SO
WE CANNOT VOTE RIGHT NOW SO WE
WILL GO TO SOON AS WE DO- IF
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
SUMMER RESPECT FOR NASSAR. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL NOW GO BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE- EIGHTY TWO FIFTEEN
AS A MEMBER TO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND FOR. YOUR FLEXIBILITY TODAY
YOU MAY. PROCEED THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- WITH YOUR INDULGENCE
I'D LIKE TO ACTUALLY TAKE UP
THE FINAL ITEM TOO BECAUSE I
HAVE A WITNESS WHO HAS TO LIVE
IN A FEW MINUTES I THOUGHT OKAY
SO LET ME RECALL THAT WE- WERE
GONNA DO NOT NUMBER ONE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. EIGHTY EIGHT ONE
SIX. YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. THE SENATORS ON
ANY GIVEN NIGHT OVER A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
ARE HOMELESS. AS THIS COMMITTEE
WELL KNOWS OUR STATE HAS THE
HIGHEST RATE OF UNSHELTERED
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COUNTRY IT'S A TOP ISSUE FOR
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
SATISFIED WITH GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSE. WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE PROGRESS ON THIS
WITH DATA DRIVEN STRATEGIES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE THIS YEAR
WHEN OUR BUDGET INCLUDES A
HISTORIC. UNPRECEDENTED TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS. WHILE DISCUSSIONS
ON HOW WE CREATE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THOSE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
ONGOING. THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
LOCAL AND STATE STRATEGIES FOR
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS TO HOLD
BOTH STATE AGENCIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE. WHAT
THE BILL DOES IS IT REQUIRES
THAT STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COMPLETE A CAPS AND
NEEDS ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE
WHAT RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. BASED ON
THAT ANALYSIS STATE AGENCIES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CREATE AN
ACTIONABLE PLAN TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS. BY NINETY
PERCENT. BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY NINE. THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES A HOMELESSNESS
INSPECTOR GENERAL. THAT CAN
HOLD THE STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
FAILING TO SUBMIT A PLAN OR FOR
NOT FOLLOWING A PLAN. IN
ADDITION TO HELP MEET THE
STATEWIDE NEED FOR CREATING
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING. HOMELESSNESS AND
A CHRONIC SITUATION. THIS BILL
WILL PRIORITIZE FEDERAL FUNDING
FROM THE NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST
FUND. FOR PROJECTS SERVING
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. CURRENTLY EIGHT
CITY RECEIVES FUNDING FROM THE
TRUST FUND. WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO OUR WITNESS.
OKAY- WE HAVE. ONE ONE TO THE
WITNESSES I BELIEVE JULIE
SNYDER AND SHARON REPORT IS
THAT CORRECT. OKAY I'M GREAT
SO- INSIDER'S REPORT YOU'LL
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES AND YOU
MAY PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OR MAYBE IT'S
STILL MORNING NOT SURE HOW HI
THIS IS JULIE SNYDER WITH THE
STANFORD INSTITUTE WE ARE
PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR A B. ONE
SIX TO CREATE ENFORCEABLE
MANDATES TO REDUCE HOW MUCH
NOW. WE ARE DEEPLY GRATEFUL
YOUR BUDGET PRIORITIZED
HELPLESSNESS CALIFORNIANS
NUMBER ONE ISSUE ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM- THE
LEADERSHIP OF YOUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IN PARTICULAR SENATOR
SCANNER AND COPIER- IS MUCH
APPRECIATED WHAT THAT
INVESTMENT NEEDS NOW IS THE
CONNECTING TISSUE THAT'LL
ENSURE THE STATE AND LOCAL
PROGRAMS AND LEVERAGE EACH
OTHER'S STRENGTHS. TO ACHIEVE
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES AB EIGHT
ONE SIX IS THAT CONNECTING
TISSUE FOR EXAMPLE THE BUDGET
PROVIDES TWO BILLION TO
LOCALITIES EIGHTY EIGHT ONE SIX
WOULD REQUIRE THEY DEVELOP A
REGIONAL GAPS A NEEDS ANALYSIS
AS THE ROAD MAP TO SPEND THE
SPOT ON THE ACTIVE
INTERVENTIONS THAT MOVE PEOPLE
QUICKLY INTO PERMANENT HOUSING.
AND NOT ONLY THAT TWO BILLION
BUT ALSO THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION COUNTIES RECEIVING THE
CALVERT HOUSING PROGRAM THE TWO
BILLION AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FINDING ECCENTRIC
CENTRAL COORDINATION OF THESE
FUNDING STREAMS WILL MEET THE
NEEDS OF MORE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. WITH
THIS FUNDING IS THE BUILD 90%
FULL ACHIEVABLE WE CAN LOOK TO
THE CITY OF BAKERSFIELD FOR ONE
EXAMPLE AS OF JANUARY THIS YEAR
THE ELIMINATED CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS THROUGH A SIX YEAR
COLLABORATION WITH PUBLIC
PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT PARTNERS.
HOW THEY DID IT THERE WAS LESS
IMPORTANT THAN THE FACT THAT
THEY FIGURED IT OUT AND ABOUT
TWENTY P. EIGHT ONE SIX CHARGES
THE STATE AND EACH LOCALITY
WITH DOING IN ANY WAY THEY FIND
FEASIBLE IT WAS COMPLETELY.
FLEXIBLE ON THE HOUSE. BEYOND
IT RIGHT. JURISDICTION TEMPTED
LEVELS OF RESEARCH. SO WHEN
1990% IS THIS. GOAL NOT A LOCAL
GROUP. EACH LOCALITIES PER.
SCHOOL WILL BASED ON WHAT HE
CAN RE. ACCOMPLISH TO REZONING
USING EXISTING DOLLARS MORE
EFFECTIVELY EXCEPT FOR US BUT
WILL NO LONGER ACCEPT INACTION
OR INEFFECTIVE APPROACHES HE B.
EIGHT ONE SIX CREIGHTON
INSPECTOR GENERAL AS WELL TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL. WE HOPE IT'S MERE
EXISTENCE WILL CREATE THE
POLITICAL WILL TO DO WHAT WE
KNOW IS POSSIBLE SHE EVERY
OUNCE OF CREATIVITY MUST BE
USED TO HELP THE GROWING NUMBER
OF OUR NEIGHBORS WHO LIVE
OUTSIDE. WE URGE YOUR EYE ON
THE. STATIONARY NOTHING MAJOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FROM SHARON REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN MEXICO AFTER ITSELF
ADMITS NIGHTER INDICATED
HOMELESSNESS IS SOLVABLE IN
FACT FIVE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
CITIES HAVE EITHER ELIMINATED-
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS OR VETERAN
HOMELESSNESS IN MICHIGAN AND
NEW JERSEY HAVE REDUCED
HOMELESSNESS SIGNIFICANTLY BY
SEVENTY AND 49% RESPECTIVELY.
BUT WE NEED FUNDING TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT EACH FINDING WAYS TO
HANDLE SUCCESSFUL STATE THAT
GOAL IS DATED TEN BEST
COLLABORATE AND COORDINATE
RESOURCES ANDIDENTIFYING
REFORM FAILED POLICY. EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN HOLD ALL THE
CALLS FOR THE GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING WHAT WORK
IT FIRST REQUIRES THE STATE TO
DO GAPS AND NEEDS ANALYSIS. TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS. WE
HAVE A STATE HOME DATA
INFORMATION SO. TO KNOW WHO
THANKS FOR HOME AND REPEAT GO
WHEN THEY ACT. WE NEXT NEED TO
KNOW HOW MANY SHELTER BEDS AT
THREE HOUSING RESOURCES WE HAVE
ANALYZED WE NEED AND IDENTIFY
THE GAPS. IT WILL ALSO PINPOINT
HOW MANY PEOPLE WE EXPECT TO
EXIT STATE FUNDED INSTITUTIONS
INTO HOMELESSNESS AND RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO PREVENT THAT
HOMELESSNESS. NAMING AND HAS
BEEN A GAME CHANGER FOR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TOUR TOOK A THINLY SOURCED AND
FILLING GAPS. IN IT SHOULD BE A
NO BRAINER FOR CALIFORNIA. NEXT
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN REQUIRES
THE STATE TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO PUT
IN PLACE CALLED **** FINALLY
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN THIRTY
GOALS FOR EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT DO THE HARD WORK OF
COLLABORATING BY PURGING
INVESTMENTS AND REFORMING
PUBLIC. THE ONLY WAY TO MEET
THE VOTER AND LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY ALL COMMENTS NO IT'S A
DEDICATE CALIFORNIANS CAN ALL
HANDS ON DECK APPROACH EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN IS TO CALL HER
BACK ON HER ALL HANDS ON DECK
CAN STOP THIS CRISIS. I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL NOW GO TO
SUPPORT A PUBLIC COMMENT SO
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TO MAKE SUPPORT OF PUBLIC
COMMENT ON A. B. THE ONE
SIXTEEN NINE WILL GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. I SEE NO ONE THERE
WHEN I GO TO THE PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR KEY PLEASE QUEUE UP.
SUPPORTIVE TESTIMONY FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT ONE SIX AND AS A REMINDER
PLEASE SIMPLY SAY YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE
FACT OF YOUR SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT ONE SEX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NINE IN Q.
BECAUSE OF MY NUMBER FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
AND MORE RED TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF SPECTRUM IN AMERICA LAMBERT
WHAT. LINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PHOBIAS POLICE SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
AFTERNOON MASON TAYLOR PROGRAM
MANAGER WTH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATE CALIFORNIA CODE
JUSTIFICATION IS REGISTERING MY
STRONG SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY. ONE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KATHY PRESS AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF BRILLIANT
CORNERS OF SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROVIDER OPERATING STATEWIDE
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT.
486-816-8816 IS A COMPREHENSIVE
STATEWIDE SOLUTION TO THE MORAL
CRISIS OF OUR TIME. IT'S STILL
CHARGES THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS ACTION ORIENTED
ENFORCEABLE PLAN. THIS IS A
CLEAR CALL TO USE ALL AVAILABLE
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS WE URGE YOU
TO PART WITH IT. THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IMAGINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MEET YOU AT THE WORD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I TREAT THE
CONCEPT BUT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
AND STRONG SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JENNIFER ALLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS ADAM LANE FROM
THE LOS ANGELES BUSINESS
COUNCIL EXPRESSING OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A. B. EIGHT SIXTEEN.
BEFORE WE OPEN LINE SIXTY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. ONE SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE
GATES WITH ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
AND AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO NO
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- OKAY WHEN I GOT OFF HIS
ISHANT AV EIGHT ONE SIX. I HAVE
A- ONE LEO CITY TO THE
OPPONENTS- BY PHONE- JOSH- GO
OVER FROM- FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND JASON RYAN. FROM THE LEAVE
CALIFORNIA CITIES- YOU'LL EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES AND- MATAMATA
READY MADE FOR C. RIGHT JOSH
DUGGAR REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
AND COUNTY. IN ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE URBAN COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND WILL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
EIGHT ONE SIX I HAVE BEEN JUST
WITH A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS TO
THE OPERATING COMMITTEE
CONSIDERATION WHEN SHARING THE
GOAL OF IMPROVING THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS AND
AGREE THAT PLANNING IS A MAJOR
PART OF THE CHEATING MEASURABLE
AND SUSTAINED PROGRESS. FOR
THAT REASON WE WORKED
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE AUTHOR
SPONSORS AND STAFF LAST YEAR ON
THE SIMILAR BILL EIGHTY THIRTY
TO SIXTY NINE. AFTER MANY
VALUABLE CONVERSATIONS WE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION TO LAST
YEAR'S BILL WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS IT WOULD HAVE TAKEN.
UNFORTUNATELY IT DID NOT
CONTINUE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BUT WE STAND READY TO
FULLY ENGAGE IN A MEANINGFUL
DIALOGUE THIS YEAR IN HOPES OF
REACHING SIMILAR COMMON GROUND.
GENERALLY OUR CONCERN WITH
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN IS THAT IT
FALLS SHORT OF BEING A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. I NEED TO
CREATE A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY
SHOULD INCLUDE ALL THE ELEMENTS
OF CLEARLY ARTICULATED GOALS
DEFINED ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR EACH LEVEL
OF GOVERNMENT COMMENSURATE
ONGOING FUNDING TO BUILD THE
RESPONSIBILITY YOU CAN ACHIEVE
THE GOALS. AND TRANSPARENT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN INCLUDE THE
MANDATE PERTAINING TO
ARTICULATE GOALS BY SPECIFYING
A CLEANING PROCESS IN REDUCTION
TARGET. IT ALSO INCLUDES
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES THROUGH
ESTABLISHING A HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS INSPECTOR GENERAL
IN THE COURT INTERVENTION
PROCESS. HOWEVER THE MEASURE
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE OTHER
ELEMENTS NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE
THE DESIRED OUTCOME THAT BEING
SAID WE REALIZED THAT NIGHT
GAVE A DYNAMIC AND EVOLVING
CONVERSATION WITH THE
HOMELESSNESS BUDGET TRAILER
BILL NEGOTIATIONS ALSO
OCCURRING AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE GAME MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT
WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF AND
VOLUNTEERS. THAT WE ENJOYED
LAST YEAR THANK YOU. GREAT MR
MEMBERS G. JASON RILEY IN CAL
CITY. I THINK THE OPPORTUNE TO
ADD TO SPEAK TODAY. I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS- ONGOING. TO HELP
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE
STATE TACKLE THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE THAT BEFORE ALL THIS
ABOUT THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE
REGIONAL CHAMPION ON THE
DEPRECIATED EFFORTS- WE
ACTUALLY STRONGLY AGREE WITH
WITH HIM AND THE NEW YORK
COUNTY COUNTERPARTS AND OTHERS.
ABOUT THE NEED TO ESTABLISH
THAT THE GAP ANALYSIS AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS THE CITY
LANE WHAT'S THE COUNTY WHEN
WHAT STATE WILL. YOU KNOW HOW
CAN YOU SOLVE HOMELESSNESS AND
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO KNOW IS WE
CANNOT DO THIS. IN ISOLATION IT
CAN'T JUST BE CITY IT CAN'T
JUST BE COUNTING THE CABINET
STATE. THAT WE HAVE TO DO THIS
TOGETHER AND THE LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA CITY THAT CERTAINLY
COMMITTED. TO BEING A PART OF
THAT SOLUTION- WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
THE BUDGET AS FAR AS- YOU KNOW
YOU'RE MARKING A HISTORIC
AMOUNT OF MONEY. FOR
HOMELESSNESS WE CERTAINLY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THOSE FUNDS. ARE
ONGOING AND PERMANENT AND WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT- PAIRED
WITH THOSE GAPS ANALYSIS PAIRED
WITH ACTION PLAN. BUT THAT IS
HOW WE ARE GOING TO ACHIEVE.
THE GOAL THAT WE ALL HAVE WHICH
IS THAT IT'S AFFECTING MILLION
ALMOST AT. A CALIFORNIA SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSIONS IN
THE COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS-
AND AS WE WERE FINE WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ENFORCEMENT.
OF STATUTES THOSE ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WE ALL
KNOW THE DETAILS MATTER- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU AND THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THOSE DETAILS.
BECAUSE I HOPE AT THE END AND
WE CAN COME TO A COMPROMISE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT. THEY CAN'T
JUST BE A HOLDING PERIOD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THINGS THAT
THEY DON'T CONTROL WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO OVERSEE THE KIND OF
WHAT WE DO CONTROL. AND A KEY
PART OF THAT IS ENSURING WE
HAVE ACCURATE AND DEDICATED
PLANS AND WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
ON GOING AND PERMIT. THE
SUPPORTERS PLANNED- AND WITH
THAT- WE HAVE WHICH WE AVEN'T
BECAUSE LAST MINUTE DECISION
NOW WHAT WE LOOK FOR
DISCONTINUE DISCUSSIONS IN
APPRECIATED. SUMMER SEPARATES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY ONE OTHER TO THE GAL FOR
EMPLOYER. OPPOSITION SAYING ON
HERE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE.
SAYING NO ONE WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE- IF YOU ARE OPPOSITION-
TO THE SP ONE SIX PLEASE SIMPLY
SAY YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IF
ANY AND THE FACT OF YOUR
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO ONE Q. OPEN
MY NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR A NUMBER OF CRITICAL TO
TALK ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS. ALSO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. BEFORE WE OPEN MY
SEVENTY SEVEN AS A REMINDER IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY EIGHT ONE SECOND YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME ONE EIGHTY SEVEN YOU'RE
NOT THE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN FOR THE COMMITTEE
FALCONS ALL THIS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS IN
OPPOSITION. IS THAT WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
OKAY GREAT WE'LL BRING HIM BACK
TO THE- COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS BILL. K.
I'VE SEEN NINE- OF COURSE WE
CONTINUE TO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
HOPEFULLY WILL HAPPEN SHORTLY
WE WILL BE ABLE TO GO RIGHT
NOW- I TO SUPPORT- THIS BILL
AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR CONTINUES
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I. WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR REALLY.
TACKLING A HARD ISSUE IT'S
GONNA BRING OPPOSITION BECAUSE
WE'RE TRYING TO ADD MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR DRESSING
ONE OF THE VERY VERY BIGGEST
ISSUES FACING OUR STATE SO I AM
RECOMMENDING AN EYE ON THIS
BILL- I SEE CENTRE CRITTERS HE
DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT. BUT FOR
NOW WE CAN HANDLE IT YET
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW CORN- BUT
WE WILL. YOU CAN MOVE IN-
HOPEFULLY AND I. WILL GET ONE
MORE MEMBER WHAT THE CURRENT-
SO IF SOME MEMBERS YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
LEE JUST THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT WITH
US ON THIS BILL AND- LET ME
JUST SAY FEW NOTES- BASED ON
WHAT THE OPPOSITION SAID FIRST
OF ALL. WE CERTAINLY HEARD FROM
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT THERE IS. A
LITTLE BIT OF A- DIFFERENCE OF
PERSPECTIVE FROM- FROM CITIES
THAT SUPPORT THIS BILL- THAT
ARE IN MANY INSTANCES
REPRESENTING CITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN REALLY STRUGGLING. TO
GRAPPLE WITH HOMELESSNESS AND
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA
ADDRESSES UNLESS ALL CITIES. OR
COUNTIES AND ALL STATE AGENCIES
ARE ENGAGED- BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION FROM.
SOME OF THE TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
REPRESENTING OTHER CITIES. AND
I JUST WAN TO SAY A FEW THINGS
FIRST OF ALL IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING
OUT. TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS A
HISTORIC UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL OF
MONEY. FOR HOMELESSNESS AND THE
NUMBER ONE THING I HEAR FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. IS AS WE DO THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES. AND
REAL DATA DRIVEN UNDERSTANDINGS
OF HOW THAT MONEY CAN BE PUT TO
GOOD USE BECAUSE THE WORST
THING THAT COULD HAPPEN IS. WE
SPEND TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
SHORT ORDER. AND AT THE END OF
THAT DAY. IF HOMELESSNESS DOES
NOT DROP. WE WILL BE ONE. WHY
WE DIDN'T REQUIRE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THIS MEASURE
IS REALLY CHEAP DISPELS REALLY
TRYING TO. TRYING TO GRAPPLE
WITH THAT- I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT- THAT- I HEAR THE
SUGGESTION THAT WE SHOULD NOT
BE HOLDING CITIES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE RESOURCES. THAT THEY DO
NOT HAVE AND I CAN AGREE WITH
THAT MORE WHICH IS WHY THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY SAYS. THAT
CITIES CANNOT BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IF THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO TACKLE IT WHAT
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO DO IS
REALLY. ANALYZE WHAT IS THE GAP
BETWEEN- THE LEVELS OF
HOMELESSNESS IN ANY CITY OR
COUNTY- AND REGION. AND WHAT
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE TO
ADDRESS IT- AND WE WOULD REALLY
ONLY BE ASKING CITIES AND
COUNTIES. TO BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE RESOURCES THEY HAVE. BUT
IT'S ONE ASPECT OF THIS BILL
THAT'S IMPORTANT IS TO KNOW THE
GAP BETWEEN WHAT. WE NEED TO
REVERSE THIS WHAT WE HAVE SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF RESOURCES
SO- ENCLOSING EVERYONE KNOWS.
THIS IS THE MORAL CRISIS OF THE
DAY. WE NEED TO HOLD OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE TO ADDRESSING THAT
AND WITH THAT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I HOPE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE CAN OF THE STUFF
FOR. THANK YOU A FAMILY MEMBER-
AND WE WILL TAKE THIS UP
PROMOTION ABOUT ONCE WE
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM- SO SOME
RICHER YOU HAVE A SECOND BILL
ITEM NUMBER ONE. EIGHTY TWO ONE
FIVE AND YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THIS BILL
WOULD PROVE IMPROVE OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR CITIES WHERE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT HAS BEEN
UNDERPERFORMING. ALL OF US
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO SERVE ON
THIS COMMITTEE KNOW THAT CITIES
DON'T BUILD HOUSING BUT THEY
HAVE A CRITICAL ROLE IN ITS
PRODUCTION FROM SONY LAND TO
ESTABLISHING BUILDING STANDARDS
TO PREVENT PROJECTS AN EIGHTY
TWO FIFTEEN WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT CITY'S ACTIONS ARE
EFFECTIVE IN FACILITATING. THE
HOUSING THEY PLANNED FOR IN
THEIR HOUSE AND ELEMENTS AND
THROUGH THE RENEWAL PROCESS IN
THREE WAYS FIRST REQUIRE CITIES
TO HAVE A MID CYCLE
CONSULTATION WITH EACH CD. IF
THEIR OVERALL OR FOR MORE
HOUSING PRODUCTION IS UNDER THE
REGIONAL AVERAGE. SECOND THE
BILL REQUIRES CITIES WHERE
PRODUCTION HAS BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY ELOW THE
REGIONAL AVERAGE TO ADOPT LOCAL
POLICIES THAT ENABLE EIGHT
CITIES PROPOSING DESIGNATION.
THIRD THE BILL ADDS THE HOUSING
CRISIS ACTIVE TWENTY NINETEEN
PASSED BY OUR RESPECTIVE HOUSES
TO THE LIST OF STATE HOUSING
LAWS THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
CAN ENFORCE. COMBINED THESE
THREE ACCOUNTABILITY STRATEGIES
WILL BETTER ENSURE THE
ALIGNMENT OF STATE AND LOCAL
GOALS TOWARDS THE CREATION OF
HOUSING AT ALL INCOME LEVELS.
AND CHIPPING AWAY AT OUR MULTI
MILLION. HOUSING UNIT DEFICIT.
APPRECIATE THE BILLS SUPPORTED
BY WIDE COALITION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ADVOCATES AS WELL AS
HOUSING PRODUCTION STAKEHOLDERS
WERE ALL INTERESTED IN SEEING.
THE COST OF HOUSING BECOME OR
THE PRICE OF HOUSING BECOME
MORE ATTAINABLE. AND AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE TO. TURN IT OVER
TO OUR MAIN WITNESS MARINA WINE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION. IT GOOD AFTERNOON
RAN AWAY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM WE'RE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR EIGHTY TWO
FIFTEEN WHICH INCREASES THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF CITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENTS ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED
AND ARE EFFECTIVE AT
FACILITATING HOUSING PRODUCTION
BUILDING ON THE EFFORTS OF
EIGHTY SEVENTY TWO OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH WE ALSO CO
SPONSORED AB TWO FIFTEEN TAKES
ANOTHER IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
ENSURING EVERY REGION IS MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS MEETING THEIR
HOUSING GOALS. ABC FIFTEEN
MAINTAINS THAT LEVEL
FLEXIBILITY BUT INCREASES
OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT
LOCAL PLANTS ARE EFFECTIVE THIS
LEGISLATION WILL NOT ONLY
IMPROVE THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
KEEP TABS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION BUT WILL ALSO OFFER
TIMELY TARGETED SUPPORT TO
JURISDICTIONS FALLING BEHIND
OUR HOUSING TARGETS HELPING
EVERY COMMUNITY STAY ON TRACK
TO BUILD THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE TO SUPPORT TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERIES SEEING NONE. NO
LOOKING FOR SUPPORT IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY TWO ONE FIVE. WHERE YOU
WE ARE SO YOU SAID YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY. AND THE
FACT OF YOUR SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
BECOME A PART OF EIGHTY TWO ONE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FOUR IN Q. ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SURE THIS IS BOB TAYLOR
REPRESENTING FIELDS SEVEN
COMPANY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY TWO FIFTEEN. ONE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WILLIAM BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING CALIFORNIA YIMBY THAT
HELP PROPERTY COMPANY- BEING
BUILT THE LAND IN THE PARK
THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THE SMALL BACKPACK ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT AND. EIGHTY TWO FIFTY.
NINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN
HIRE FROM THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT T. V. IF YOU
COULD SEE THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIMBERLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. LINE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
PHILADELPHIA CLAIMS HERE WE
HAVE A TELECOM DAILY AT HOME
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BEFORE WE OPEN MY NINETY TWO AT
THE REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO ONE
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THE TWO
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. YOUR
TURN MEMBERS THEIR NAME ALONG
ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE ON THE PART. OKAY
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION TO AB
TWO ONE FIVE- WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED TO THE OPPOSITION
WHEN IT SAYS VALERIE FELDMAN
FROM THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
PROJECT. AND JASON RYAN FROM
LEAVE CALIFORNIA CITIES YOU'LL
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES. HI THIS
IS VALERIE FELDMAN FROM THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MY
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS THE
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT JOINED
OUR OPPOSITION LETTER TO EIGHTY
TWO ONE FIVE. FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS I HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN ADVOCACY REGARDING
HOUSING ELEMENT COMPLIANCE
THROUGHOUT THE STATES AND
DOZENS OF JURISDICTIONS AND
HAVE BEEN A PART OF SUCCESSFUL
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS. INCLUDING
LITIGATION THAT HAS RESULTED IN
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF LAND
REZONED TO ACCOMMODATE THE
JURISDICTIONS LOWER INCOME
HOUSING NEEDS. AS WELL AS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROGRAMS THAT
FACILITATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION THIS INCLUDES
ACTIONS IN THE COUNTIES OF
SHASTA HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
SACRAMENTO AND FRESNO. AND THE
CITIES OF RIVERSIDE FOLSOM
FRESNO AND THE NEEDED CLOTHING
AND MORE. WE HAVE BOTH EIGHTY
TWO FIFTEEN FOR SEVERAL
REASONS. FIRST FOR MY YEARS OF
HOUSING ELEMENT ADVOCACY I'VE
LEARNED THAT EFFECTIVE LAND USE
LAWS INCLUDE SPECIFIC
PROPHECIES. SPECIFIC CRITERIA
AND SPECIFIC DEADLINES THIS
BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE THOSE
CRUCIAL SPECIFICS. SECOND ONE
OF THE KEY COMPONENTS THE
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW IS THE
OBLIGATION TO ENGAGE THE PUBLIC
INCLUDING A DILIGENT EFFORT TO
INCLUDE PEOPLE FROM ALL INCOME
LEVELS IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE HOUSING ELEMENT. THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES HAVE TO SEEK INPUT
FROM THE PEOPLE DIRECTLY
AFFECTED BY THE HOUSING CRISIS
TO DETERMINE THE BEST WAY TO
ADDRESS THEIR HOUSING NEEDS.
THERE IS NO PUBLIC PROCESS
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL AND
NOTIFY MECHANISM FOR THE PEOPLE
MOST AFFECTED BY THE HOUSING
ELEMENT EFFECTIVENESS. TO
PROVIDE INPUT INTO THE PROPOSED
PROCESS. AND LASTLY THE BILL IS
NOT AN EFFICIENT USE OF ACT'S
RESOURCE AND TIME OR DEATH. THE
BILL CAST A VERY WIDE DEBT THAT
MIGHT SUBJECT YOUR ADDICTION TO
A REVIEW WHEN THERE MAY BE
FACTORS OUTSIDE OF THEIR
CONTROL THAT DIMINISH THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ITS HOUSING
ELEMENT PROGRAM. TEMPERATURES
SECTIONS WHERE THAT IS NOT THE
CASE. ATV ALREADY HAS THE
AUTHORITY AND NOW THE STAFFING
TO REMEDY ANY FAILURE TO
IMPLEMENT. IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. MR
HERE MEMBERS CHASING RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES. I HAVE THE
UNFORTUNATE CAPTIVES OPPOSING
BOTH OF MR XI'S BILLS TODAY-
BUT UNFORTUNATELY YES WE ARE
CLOSE TO EIGHTY TWO ONE FIVE-
YOU KNOW OUR PRIMARY CONCERN
WITH THIS MEASURE IS THAT IT
TRYING TO TRANSFORM. AN
INCENTIVE BASED PROGRAM WHICH
IS THAT PRO HOUSING DESIGNATION
PROGRAM. OVER EACH CD INTO A
PUNITIVE APPROACH WHERE OUR
CITIES WE MANDATED TO TAKE
CERTAIN ACTIONS BASED ON
ANOTHER PERFORMANCE THAT- HOW
DO PRODUCTION I BE LIKE OUR
LAST WITNESS THAT MENTION B.
WELL BEYOND THEIR CONTROL- THIS
IS THE- INCENTIVE BASED PROGRAM
THAT WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OTHERS ON. JUST
TWO SHORT YEARS AGO- AND THAT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED
YET- IN OUR CITIES HAVEN'T EVEN
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROACTIVELY SEEK THIS CALL OUT
THE DESIGNATION. SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE GREATER
COMPETITIVENESS WHEN IT COMES
TO CERTAIN PARTS OF FUNDING.
I'M VERY CENTRAL TO THE
CREATION ALL HORRIBLE HOUSING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. SO
UNFORTUNATELY WITH WITH THE-
TRANSFORMATION THAT PROGRAM WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS
IT IS NOW- ADDITIONALLY WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE MID
CYCLE REVIEW THE ENHANCEMENT OF
THAT- THAT ARE CONTAINED IN THE
MEASURE NOW- I CAN SAY THOUGH
THAT THE ASSEMBLY OVER STAFF-
HAS BEEN MORE THAN WILLING TO
REACH OUT TO US AND THAT
NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS. I KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
MORE CONVERSATION WITH THIS
WRITER ROOMS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE. I'M OVER THE SUMMER
AND THEN AS WE NEAR THE END OF
THE SESSION. IT'S MY HOPE THAT
WE CAN COME TO SOME SORT OF
COMPROMISE AND PERHAPS LEAD
THAT INCENTIVE BASED PROGRAM
UNTOUCHED. AND THEN MAYBE FOCUS
MORE ON ON WHAT COULD BE SOME
APPROPRIATE MID CYCLE. REVIEWS
WITHOUT GOING TOO FAR AS TO
SUBJECT OUR CITIES TO YET
ANOTHER HOUSING ELEMENT
BASICALLY FOR A YEAR'S END. TO
THE EXISTING IN YOUR CYCLE. AND
WITH THAT WE- OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- IS THERE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
GALLERY. SAYING NINE IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION ROOM ONE TWELVE
EIGHTEEN NINE- IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
AND AGAIN PLEASE JUST SAY YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY. AND
THE FACT OF YOUR OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY TWO ONE FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE SEVEN Q.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. I
LIVE IN BROKEN SINCE AT
PARKSIDE DISTRICT OF SAN
FRANCISCO. IN OPPOSITION. ONE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KARABAKH ON BEHALF OF
THE MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF
MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
OPPOSITION. NINE EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS CAN
RESULT ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
OPPOSITION. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OR THE
COMMITTEE PAUL BINS ALL THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
SERENO'S NORWALK PALM DESERT
ROOSEVELT AND THOUSAND OAKS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THE LINE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF CHRISLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON YOUR LAWLER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORLD LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL PRODUCTIVE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN OPPOSITION.
NINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHARING INVOLVED IS
WHAT THE RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY TO
BELMONT CARLSBAD CORONA
EASTVALE IN FOSTER CITY AN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND
BEFORE WE OPEN NINE SEVENTY TWO
AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF A. B. TWO ONE
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS. THIS IS AJ
HAD BEEN ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATE. WE ARE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY-
WILL NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. COLLEAGUES ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ABOUT
THIS BILL. OKAY SENDER BATES A
YES ON TO THE AUTHOR. FAMILY
MEMBER TO FIVE I DON'T
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS PRO
HOUSING DESIGNATION THAT USED
TO BE VOLUNTARY I FIGURED IT TO
BE SOMETHING IN TO INCENTIVIZE
AND NOW IT'S MANDATED AND
ALMOST SEEMS PUNITIVE COULD YOU
GIVE A LITTLE- BROADER
EXPLANATION OF WHY. WE HAVE
THAT AS SOMETHING THAT EACH CD
COMES DOWN IN CITIES ABOUT.
THIS SEEMS TO BE KIND OF OUT OF
CONTEXT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO TO MOVE OUR CITIES IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND LOOK FOR
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO- NEED RAIN
NINE AND OUR CERTAINLY. OUR
BALANCE OF HOUSING IN IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. CERTAINLY SO A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT AGAIN FOR
THIS BILL AS WE KNOW WE ARE
ASKING. THE STATE AND CITIES TO
PUT A TON OF TIME AND- TO
DEVELOPING HOUSING ELEMENTS IN
RENO. AND ONCE HOUSING HOMES
ARE DOTTED BASICALLY. NO ONE
REALLY LOOKS AT THEM AGAIN FOR
EIGHT YEARS TO SEE IF CITIES
ARE DOING. WHAT THEY HAD
PLANNED TO DO SO WHAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS IS REALLY
REALLY BAD. WHAT PART OF WHAT
THIS BILL IS SAYING IS FOR
CITIES THAT ARE WOEFULLY
UNDERPERFORMING IN THAT AREA-
WE WANT THEM TO ACHIEVE THE PRO
HOUSING DESIGNATION WITH THE
PRO HOUSING DESIGNATION DOES
IS. IT SAYS THE CITIES THAT ARE
DOING A GOOD JOB IN THIS AREA
YOU ARE GOING TO GET IF I COULD
PUT IT THIS WAY. CARATS
INCENTIVES ARE TO MOVE FORWARD-
THOSE WOULD INCLUDE- BEING ABLE
TO- TO POTENTIALLY GET MORE FOR
MORE FUNDING- AND BEING ABLE TO
MOVE MOVE THIS FORWARD AND PART
OF WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS TO THE
WORST PERFORMING CITIES. WE
WANT YOU TO STRIVE WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THE PRO
HOUSING DESIGNATION ALLOWS TO
STRIVE TO DO WHAT YOU NEED TO
DO TO MAKE SURE- THAT YOU'RE
BUILDING THE HOUSING THAT YOU
ARE NOW ALL THAT BEING SAID I
WANT TO STATE THIS. OUT TO YOU
AND TO OTHER STAKEHOLDERS WE
ARE IN DISCUSSIONS RIGHT NOW
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
THIS VERY ISSUE WHAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE WAY. TO UTILIZE
WHAT HAPPENED THE CARROTS THE
INCENTIVES OF THE PRESENT AS A
NATION AND REALLY MOVE EVERYONE
FORWARD. THAT CONVERSATION IS
ONGOING AND I'M COMMITTING TO
ALL STAKEHOLDERS WHO REALLY
REALLY WANT TO TAKE A GOOD LOOK
AT HOW TO USE TO YOUR POINT
WHAT HUSBAND STRUCTURED AS SORT
OF INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. AS A WAY
TO MOVE EVERYONE BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY WE WANT ALL CITIES
TO BE PRO HOUSE IN CITIES
IDEALLY EVERY CITY IN THE
STATE. GETS THE DESIGNATION
BUT- AT THE MOMENT IT'S ONLY
THOSE CITIES THAT. LET'S SAY
THE BEST PERFORMING CITIES THAT
WILL GET IT. AND THEN WE HAVE A
LOT OF OTHER CITIES THAT LOAN
AND AGAIN PART OF WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT IT SORT OF
BRIDGES PUSHES. THOSE WORST
PERFORMANCE CITIES TO MOVE FOR.
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXPLANATION
AND IT JUST SEEMS TO BE UPSIDE
DOWN TO ME IT WOULD BE TO ME
HAVING SERVED AT. BOTH LEVELS
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT COUNTY FOR
pA LOT OF DEVELOPMENT WAS GOING
ON DURING MY TERM. IN OFFICE
AND ALSO- AS A FOUNDING. MEMBER
OF THE CITY COUNCIL AND NOW
I'M- SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY WHERE
YOU KNOW DEVELOPMENT WAS SIGN
GOING- IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THOSE THAT ARE UNDER PERFORMING
DON'T DO THAT PURPOSEFULLY.
THAT THERE ARE OBSTACLES
WITCHER FEES FIVE AND THE
REGULATIONS PUT ON THEM BY THE
STATE. OF THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
SHOULD BE INCENTIVISED A IF
OTHERS ARE MEETING AT HIM
GETTING A DESIGNATION OF PRO
HOUSING IS PROBABLY LIKE
GETTING AN H. AND THEY'RE
ALREADY PERFORMING AT THAT
LEVEL AND YOU'RE GIVING THE
OTHER GUYS YOU'RE TRYING TO
HELP AN ELF. SO I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING THAT. YOU
WERE KIND OF RE LOOK AT THAT- I
CAN'T SUPPORT IT TODAY. AGAIN
HAVING SERVED AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE NUMBER OF
YEARS THAT IDEA AND WHICH IS
ABOUT SIXTEEN. THERE IS-
COMPLETELY UPSIDE DOWN VIEW OF
WHAT OUR CITIES TRY TO DO AND
THE OBSTACLES THAT ARE PLACED
ON. IN FRONT OF THEM USUALLY BY
SOME. RATHER A-
MISUNDERSTANDING A COOKIE
CUTTER APPROACH. TO WHAT'S
GOING OUT. ON OUT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- EIGHT THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING BECAUSE IT IS. A
NOBLE CAUSE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE HOUSE. HOUSING FOR
PRESENT AND FUTURE GENERATIONS
THAT TOM I JUST SEE IT SOMEWHAT
UPSIDE DOWN SINCE I WAS AT THE-
BELIEVE IF YOU WILL WITH A
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT CHILD
INCORPORATED AND DEVELOPED IN
AND PROVIDED INCREDIBLE.
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES AT EVERY
LEVEL WE APPROACH THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU AND IN THE
DAYS THAT WOULD BE IN IN THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES AS A
PLANNED COMMUNITY PLAN
RECOGNIZED BY. CONGRESS AT THAT
TIME AS ONE OF THE BEST
APPROACHES TO. URBAN LAND
PLANNING- WHICH PROVIDED
OPPORTUNITIES THAT YOU COULD
LIVE WORK AND- PLAY AND YOUR
COMMUNITY GOES TO ALL THE
THINGS YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH NOW. AND THAT IS
BEEN KIND OF LOST OVER THE
YEARS THAT SHOULD BE REVISITED.
BUT THANK YOU AGAIN AND I MEAN
NO DISRESPECT THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK THAT STILL NEEDS TO BE
DONE ON THIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. OKAY SEEING NONE- WE-
OR ONE SORT OF A QUORUM ARE
ALMOST THERE- AND WE WILL TAKE
THIS UP FOR THE MOTION IN A
VOTE WHEN WE SEE A CAR ON A
SEMI NUMBER YOU MAKE ONCE AGAIN
VERY MUCH APPRECIATING GAUGE ON
ON THIS THE CONVERSATION WILL
CONTINUE I THINK AGAIN I THINK
THE GOAL FOR ALL OF US IS TO
MAKE ALL OF OUR CITIES TO BE
PRO HUSING CITIES- DO YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT THE NEW PRO
HOUSING DESIGNATION IS
RELATIVELY NEW SO- WE'RE
WORKING TO THESE ISSUES BUT AS
FAR AS PARTICULAR OTHER ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. VERY MUCH SO WE
CAN MOVE ALL THIS FORWARD AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
SUPPORT AT THE RIGHT TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY I SEE
THAT AS A MEMBER WARDERS HERE
SO WE WILL PROCEED TO ITEM
NUMBER. SIX EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
ONE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS EIGHTY FOUR
NINE ONE SIX TO CLARIFY A
STATEWIDE STANDARD TO ENSURE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RESIDENTS
HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO COMMON
ENTRANCES AREAS AND AMENITIES
AS MARGAERY HOUSING RESIDENTS
CURRENTLY SOME DEVELOPERS ARE
SEEKING TO BUILD A HOUSING
STRUCTURE CONTAINING BOTH
MARKET RATE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS THEY HAVE SOUGHT
TO CONSTRUCT THAT STRUCTURE
WITH SEPARATE COMMON ENTRANCES
COMMON AREAS OR COMMON
AMENITIES FOR EACH SET OF
OCCUPANTS. ONE RECENT EXAMPLE
IN MY DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO
WOULD HAVE CREATED SEPARATE
ENTRANCES AND RESTRICTED
CERTAIN AMENITIES INCLUDING A
POOL AND A ROOFTOP DECK TO ONLY
THE RESIDENTS OF MARKET RATE
UNITS IN EFFECT DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EXCEEDING AFFORDABLE UNIT
RESIDENCE. AS THE STATE
CONTINUES TO ENCOURAGE MORE
MAKES DUNK IT IN MIXED INCOME
HOUSING THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WE NEED TO BE EXPLICITLY CLEAR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RESIDENTS
SHOULD NOT BE TREATED AS SECOND
CLASS CITIZENS WHILE THE SAN
DIEGO PROJECT WAS REVISED IT
DEPENDED ON PUBLIC PRESSURE
RATHER THAN CLEAR EXISTING LAW
TO STOP THE PLAN
DISCRIMINATION. EIGHTY FOUR
NINE ONE SIMPLY AN EXPLICITLY
CLARIFIES THAT RESIDENTS OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN A MIXED
INCOME MULTI FAMILY DEVELOPMENT
MUST HAVE THESAME ACCESS TO
COMMON ENTRANCES AREAS AND
AMENITIES AS THE OCCUPANTS OF
MARKET RATE UNITS. NOW I'D LIKE
TO PRESENT MY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL CREAM
DRESSY. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELL WHEN I GO
TO. PRINTERS FROM. YES THE
LONGER RATHER THAN JUST HOLD ON
ONE SECOND WE ARE A LOOSE OF.
HER LOOSE OF CORN HAS BEEN.
ESTABLISHED AND SO SHE'S IN A
IN THE BACK- SO OUR OUR
GOVERNMENT HAS ESTABLISHED FORM
AND THEN WE WILL PROCEED WITH
THEIR WITNESSES- SHE'S. WE WERE.
OKAY YOU ARE AMERICANS ALL CAN
YOU ESTABLISH KERR CALLED ROLL.
SENATOR WIENER PRESIDENT WINTER
PRESENT DATES HERE IT'S PRESENT
COURTESY. COURTESY PRESENT
COPYRIGHT. REQUIRE THE TROUBLE.
YEAH. BUT YOUR BOOK. PRESIDENT
SKINNER- BERKSHIRE AMBER
PRESENTLY CASKEY. OKAY WE HAVE
A QUORUM THANK YOU BYE OKAY SO
WHEN I GO BACK TO CREAM TRICITY
APOLOGIZE FOR THE INTERRUPTION
YOU MAY PRODUCE TESTIMONY. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR-
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS. CA ARE THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
ONE WHICH HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ZERO NO
VOTE HERE TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MAY HAVE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN IDOL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. HEY IS THERE ANY SUPPORT
OF PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN THE
SENATE GALLERY. C. NINE FIVE
ROOM ONE TWELVE SAME NUMBER GO
TO THE PHONE LINES. I AM NOT A
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP SUPPORTIVE TESTIMONY.
I'D BE GLAD TO SEE HER LADIES
AND GNTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
AT THE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD JUST
BECAUSE THE PORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE JOINT REPORT. OKAY
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION WE
HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
IDENTIFIED AS ARE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NINE- ROOM ONE TWELVE C. NINE-
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY ONE OF THE PHONE
LINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY FOUR NINETY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THE TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE SHOWING UP ON. OKAY
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- COLORS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ABOUT
THIS BILL. OKAY I WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE-
ANDS. I SEE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- SO I AM- RECOMMENDING
AND I VOTE ON THIS BILL I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS. FORWARD THIS IS
BEEN A RECURRING ISSUE WERE
SEEN THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY-
FRANKLY AND I THINK IT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE. TO HAVE CLEAR
STANDARDS IN THE LOSS OF THAT-
DEVELOPERS KNOW. WHAT THE RULES
ARE AND IT DOESN'T. BECOME AN
AD HOC PUBLIC PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN. ON A PARTICULAR-
PROJECT- SO WITHTHAT AS A
MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ
HE- AND- WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A SYMBOL FOR NINETY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WINNER.
WINNER I'D BATES HI BATES-
CARRERO. CORTEZ C. CORTEZ THE I
AM ACQUIRE A CHORE BOOK. THE
TROUBLED BY SKINNER I'M BURKE.
HI NUMBER FIVE WITH CASCADE.
FIVE HAS FIVE VOTES WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL- AND BEFORE WE GET
TO SOME MEMBER FREEMEN UNLESS
YOU'RE IN A SUPER SUPER RUSH- I
JUST GOT A WE HAVE A QUORUM I
WANT TO JUST GO BACK AND DO THE
INITIAL VOTES ON THE OTHER
THREE ITEMS SO WE'LL GO BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE- EIGHTY TWO
FIFTEEN BY SOME NUMBER TWO-
PLEASE- DRIVEN MOTION ON THE
TWO POINT 5% RECORD HAS A-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS A
SEMI BILL TO FIFTEEN BY TO A
FAMILY MEMBER TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER I'D BATES. NO IT'S NO
COPYRIGHT. COURTESY COURTESY I
REQUIRE. A CHEWABLE. THE
TROUBLE NOW SKINNER I'M BURKE
HI NUMBER WHAT CASKEY. THREE
TWO OKAY WE WILL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL ONE EXTRA ITEM NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT ONE SIX FIVE
SEVEN NUMBER TWO- MOTION BY
SENATOR CORTEZ HE- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS A SUMMARY
BILL EIGHT ONE SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TRUE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES SENATOR WIENER
HI WINNER I'D BATES. BATES NO
COPYRIGHT. COURTESY COURTESY
I'VE ACQUIRED. A CHORE BOOK NOW
THE CHOPPER KNOW SKINNER- BURKE
HI NUMBER FIVE WITH CASKEY
THREE TWO. WE WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL FOR ACTION MEMBERS WILL
NOW GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY SEVEN
MEMBER GRAYSON- WE HAVE A
MOTION. THE MOTION. CIRCUIT HAS
HE WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE OUR
MOTION MAKE DAY CENTER BECAUSE
HE- WILL CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
A SUMMARY BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SENATOR
WINNER. WINNER I'D BATES. BATES
KABIRA COURTESY. COURTESY I'D
REQUIRE WOULD SHOW A BOOK. THE
TROUBLE EYES SCANNER- BURKE. OF
BURKE- I WOULD CASCADE. FIVE
ZERO OKAY WE WILL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL PERHAPS THE MEMBERS-
WE'RE NOT CAUGHT UP AND WE'LL
GO TO ITEM NUMBER. ONE AND I'M
SORRY THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CALENDAR WHICH IS ITEMS THREE
FOUR AND SEVEN- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR TED Z. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON THE CONSECUTIVE
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS
THREE FOUR AND SEVEN. SENATOR
WIENER. FIGHT WINNER I'D BATES
HI IT'S A CAREER- CORTEZ HE-
RETURNS THE ITEM ACQUIRE THE
TROUBLE. THE TROUBLED EYES
SCANNER NUMBER. AMBER CASKEY.
FIVE ZERO OKAY WE'LL PUT THAT
ON COVER OF THE MEMBERS OKAY A
SUMMONER FREEMAN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE- WELCOME THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE- WE'LL BE
HEARING ITEM TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT AND YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WE ALL KNOW THAT
BUILDING CODES ARE INTENDED TO
MAKE SURE THAT BUILDINGS ARE
SAFE FOR THEIR INHABITANTS. AND
ENFORCEMENT OF THESE CODES IS
EXPRESSIONLESS CRITICAL IN
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING WHERE
TENANTS HAVE A LIMITED ABILITY
TO THEMSELVES CORRECT ANY
HEALTH OR SAFETY PROBLEMS THE
INSPIRATION FOR THIS BILL FOR
ME WAS READING A ARTICLE IN THE
LA S. MAGAZINE ABOUT SOME SOME
REAL SLUM PROPERTIES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WERE
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
ENFORCEMENT THE TENANTS WERE
FORCED TO DO THINGS LIKE USE
ILLEGAL SPACE HEATERS THE
WIRING WAS BAD IN THE BUILDING.
A FIRE ENSUED AND CHILDREN WERE
KILLED IN THIS FIRE AND THESE
WERE TENANTS WHO WERE POWERLESS
TO COMPEL THE SAFETY ON THE
ROAD AND MAKING IT WORSE THE
BUILDING OFFICIALS IN THAT CITY
WE'RE NOT DOING CODE
ENFORCEMENT ON THIS PROPERTY
THE UNFORTUNATE FACT IS THAT WE
STILL HAVE A FEW CITIES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT PUT
PRE CONDITIONS ON TENANTS.
BEFORE THEY WILL DO INSPECTIONS
ABOUT SAFETY VIOLATIONS
SOMETIMES THOSE PRECONDITIONS
SAID THAT THE TENANTS HAVE TO
BE CURRENT ON ALL THEIR RENT
BEFORE THE LOOK AT WHETHER THE
BUILDING IS SAFE OR THAT THEY
HAVE TO PROVE PROVE THAT THEY
HAD GONE TO THE LANDLORD FIRST
NONE OF THAT'S ABOUT HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ALL THAT THEY SHOULD
CARE ABOUT IS ENSURING THAT
EVERY SINGLE UNIT IS SAFE. FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT PROHIBITS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA FROM PLACING
RESTRICTIONS OR PRECONDITIONS
BEFORE RESPONDING. TO
COMPLAINTS OF HABITABILITY
ISSUES THESE ARE SERIOUS SAFETY
COMPLAINTS. AB EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT DOES NOT. CREATE ANY NEW
DUTIES OR RESPONSIBILITIES ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. I DON'T
EXPECTED TO INCLUDE IT AND
CHANGED IT OR INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS IN
CALIFORNIA. ALL IT DOES IS SAY
THAT THEY CAN'T PRECONDITION.
INSPECTIONS ON IT ON THE
TENANT. NOW WITH ATTENDED
ENTERS A CONTRACT WITH THE
LANDLORD IT'S COMMON KNOWLEDGE
THAT THE LAND IT'S GOING TO BE
THEIR FIRST LINE. OF CONTACT IF
THEY HAVE AN ISSUE AT A. B.
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT DOES NOT
CHANGE THAT UNDERLYING FACT.
OUR OFFICE HAS HAD VERY
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
REALTORS AND THE
REPRESENTATIVES FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM. TO
RESOLVE THE ONE OUTSTANDING
ISSUE ABOUT COST RECOVERY THAT
PROPERTY OWNERS BELIEVE THAT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THE COST OF INSPECTIONS
THAT DON'T REVEAL VIOLATIONS.
WE AGREE WITH THAT AND THAT'S
WHY WE'VE AMENDED THIS BILL TO
STATE. THAT PROPERTY OWNERS
WILL NOT BE LIABLE FOR AN
INSPECTION. AND LESS THE
INSPECTION REVEALS A MATERIAL
AND SUBSTANTIAL VIOLATIONS OF
THE CODE. THAT IS STANDARD
PRACTICE AS FAR AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT IN ALMOST ALL OF
OUR CITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND SO WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT
THAT. CONTINUES UNDER THIS
BILL. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY OR CYNTHIA CASTILLO FROM
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. AND BRIAN AUGUSTA FROM
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. FOR THE
SAFETY OF OUR. RESIDENTS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE.
I THANK YOUR SUMMER AND MONEY I
NEGLECT TO. MENTION AT THE
BEGINNING OF DECEMBER THAT
INTRODUCES BILL LAST YEAR- AND
BECAUSE OF THE COVER PANDEMIC
WE HAD TO. REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
BILLS- AND I WAS CALLING AROUND
SOME MEMBERS FOR VOLUNTEERS
ABOUT- SO AS NOT TO BE HEAVY
HANDED AND THIS SUMMER WAS KIND
ENOUGH. TO VOLUNTEER TO THE FOR
HER BILL TO THIS YEAR SO I'M
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THAT. SO
I'M NOT JUST AN I. RECOGNITION
TO DOUBLE I RECOMMENDATION. ON
THIS VERY GOOD BILLS- WILL NOW
GO TO OUR LEAD. WITNESSES ON
THIS BILL WHO ARE. BY CIVIC STR
BRENDA GOT STUCK YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
BIGGEST DEAL WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY HERE
IN PORT EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH WE
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR. EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE INSERT A CROP OF
BACON REQUEST INSPECTION EITHER
HOME OR SPONSOR DEFICIENCY
WITHOUT HAVING AN INAPPROPRIATE
CONDITION PLACED ON THE RIGHT
SECTION I WOULD THINK LARGEST
AND OLDEST SUPPORT CENTER AND
WE HEAR FROM LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE
REPRESENT LOW INCOME RENTERS IF
SOMETHING BIG BARRIERS WHEN
ASKING FOR AN INSPECTION. YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO POINT AT
TIMES THEY ARE TOLD THAT BEFORE
AN INSPECTOR CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THE HOUSING ESTATE THE BIGGEST
JUMP THROUGH HOOPS FOR THAT
SECTION TO OCCUR. CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY IMPOSES UNIFORM
OBLIGATIONS ON ALL LANDLORDS TO
MAINTAIN RENTAL PROPERTY BE
FREE FROM DEFECTS SUCH AS THE
MALL THE DEFECTIVE WIRING AND
THE LIFE. INSURANCE
APPLICATIONS ARE MATH IS A
UNIVERSAL EXPECTATIONS EVERY
DAY BOTH HANDS AND RAN ACROSS.
THE WORK TOGETHER QUICKLY
ADDRESS. NO MY FRIEND. ARE
LIABLE IF EVER EARLY GOVERNMENT-
LANDLORD IT'S SIMPLY INSERT THE
UP AGAIN PART FOR. EIGHT THREE
PROVIDE THE FACT FOR THE WORK
WITH WORK VIOLATORS HEALTH MY-
THEY AND EVERY LOCAL. HAS AN
INTEREST IN ENSURING ME W. AND
YOU KNOW A LOT PROPERTY
DETERIORATE AS WE WORK WITH%
OVER UNDER HOUSING. AND OUR
CURRENT HEALTH CRISIS. EIGHT
THREE IN THE COMMENTS FELT THAT
WE WILL ENSURE TEMPER AFFORDED
EQUAL RIGHTS IN FOURTH MEMBER
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS FOR
HOUSING INVESTORS ARE HOW WE
GOT TO PROTECT ANYTHING. IT
PROTECTED FROM DANGEROUS OR
UNHEALTHY CONDITIONS IN OUR
HOUSE. FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE SIMPLE YET MEANINGFUL BELT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU-
MR GOT STUCK. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRIAN I GOT-
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION- THE AUTHOR AND MY
COLLEAGUE I'VE ALREADY LAID OUT
VERY WELL THE DEEPEST PHILLIPS
I DO WANT TO NOTE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THAT THIS IS A-
PROBLEM THAT IS PARTICULARLY
ACUTE. ACUTE IN. IN RURAL AREAS
IN OUR LEGAL SERVICES
COLLEAGUES ALL THE TIME ABOUT.
THE COUNTERING EXACTLY THE
PROBLEM IS THE AUTHOR. OF
DYSTROPHIC- CAN I GET THE
RELIEF THAT THE LAW- PROMISES
DOWN WHICH IS THAT. THE
GOVERNMENT WILL COME OUT
INSPECTED IN ORDER THE LANDLORD
TO COMPLY WITH THE CODE. THIS
BILL ENSURES THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE THAT MEANS DOLLARS AND
BALANCE. THE DESCRIBED ABOUT
HOW COSTS WILL BE ALLOCATED FOR
IT FOR THAT REASON WE CAN GET
THE- IMPORTANT BELLAMY RELIGION
I LOVE. OKAY IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT OF TESTIMONY HERE IN
THE SENATE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. SAY
NO ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP SUPPORT. FOR A. B.
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT. CERTAINLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD JUST BECAUSE THE PORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
JUST BECAUSE THE PORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO INSURANCE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR. OKAY A MOTION BY
SENATOR CORTEZ HE- AND AGAIN I
AM RECOMMENDING AN EYE ON THIS
BILL. SO MY MEMBER YOU MAY
CLOSE. THE SPECTRALLY REQUESTS
AND I BOTH. THANK YOU WE WILL-
COLORADO. THIS IS A SUMMARY
BILL EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. OH MY APOLOGIES I
THOUGHT WE DID OPPOSITION I'M
SO SORRY. OKAY I THOUGHT WE DID
OPPOSITION MADAM MODERATOR
DEGREE. WE HAVE NOT YET TO
RESTART OPPOSITION NOW OKAY MY
SINCEREST APOLOGIES WHEN THERE
IS AN OPPONENT I'M SO SORRY- WE
HAVE IS OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
CREAMS RECEIPT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.MESSAGES IN MY
SINCEREST APOLOGIES YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR-
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CREAMED ON THE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- AS RECENTLY AMENDED
EIGHTY EIGHT CREATE NOW
PROTECTS SMALL HOUSING
PROVIDERS. WHO ARE CONTAINERS
INDIVIDUAL COLOR FROM BEING
UNFAIRLY CHARGED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TRANSACTION THAT DID
NOT REVEAL ANY SUBSTANTIAL
MATERIAL VIOLATIONS- WE
SINCERELY APART THE AUTHOR OF
THE SPONSORS FOR MANY THE BILL
TO INCLUDE THESE PROVISIONS
THANK VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT LANGUAGE
REPRESENTS A COMPROMISE
LANGUAGE THAT IT HAD INPUT FROM
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS-
UNFORTUNATELY IS IT IS STILL
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
PLANE WHICH MAY BE
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGE IN THE
FUTURE DUE TO ONGOING INPUT
FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS- BECAUSE
IT IS UNCLEAR WITH THESE
PENDING CHANGES WILL LOOK LIKE.
AND HOW THEY WILL IMPACT SMALL
HOUSING PROVIDERS TO PLAY BY
THE RULES WE MUST MAINTAIN AN
OPPOSING WITH MEDITATION ON
EIGHTY EIGHT CREATE. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO KNOW.
BOTH AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OKAY IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY. SAME
NINE ROOM ON TWELVE. SEEING NO
ONE THERE OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE- QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONES AND AGAIN PLEASE
SAY YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
IF ANY AND THE FACT OF YOUR
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY THE PRODUCT ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO IN Q. ONE NINETY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES- HOPING
TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS WITH THE
CHAIRS AND ALL JENSEN THERE WAS
ONLY ONE WE WITNESS. YOU MAY
PROCEED. I THINK YOU I FIRST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH THE FAQ AND OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS
TO RESOLVE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
OUR CONCERNS WITH THIS MEASURE-
AS NOTED WE DO STILL HAVE ONE
OUTSTANDING CONCERN WHICH IS
THE LANGUAGE RELATED TO THE
IMPOSITION OF FEES FOR
INSPECTIONS THAT REVEALED
VIOLATIONS- I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THAT PROCESS IN
THE BILL IS LIMITED TO A SUBSET
OF VIOLATIONS. AND WE THINK
THAT THE CURRENT LANGUAGE IS
OVERLY BROAD AND WOULD RESTRICT
IMPOSITION OF B. S. IF WE GO
OUT TO INSPECT AND FIND
VIOLATIONS OF OTHER BUILDING
STANDARDS OWNING STANDARDS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE TO THAT
END OUR COALITION HAS PROPOSED
LANGUAGE TO THE AUTHOR AND-
REALTORS AS OF LAST WEEK AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TO
RESOLVE. THIS REMAINING CONCERN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINES. YES WE HAVE
ONE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY RYAN
ON BEHALF OF THE WORLD K.
REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO THE LEGAL CALIFORNIA
CITIES WITH LIKE A MINOR COMMON
CREEK WE- WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS- ENGAGEMENT WITH US AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET. A
POSITION OF NEUTRAL THANK YOU.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT
THREE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE- OPPOSING
THE BILL. THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IS THAT
EMOTION OR QUESTION. COMMENTS
FROM A COMMENT BY CENTER
DESIGNATION I JUST WANT. TO
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE- JUST
SAYS THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AS IT
SOUNDS LIKE. IS HAPPENING THEN
I'LL RENEW THE MOTION THAT WAS
MADE EARLIER- LITTLE
PREMATURELY. THANK YOU SEVEN
MEMBER. I YEAH I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT WE AGREED WITH THE CONCERN
FROM THE REALTORS I THINK THAT
THAT IS- JUSTIFY CONCERN WHICH
IS WHY I THINK WE TOOK THEIR
LANGUAGE. AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR CONCERN IS
ADDRESSED- AND THAT- THAT. WE
HAVE NOT FOUND ANY CITY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S ACTUALLY
CHARGING THE LANDLORDS FOR
DOING THESE INSPECTIONS ANYWAY
BUT WE ALSO ARE SENSITIVE THAT
THEY DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN
AND WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM TO
HAVE LANGUAGE THAT EVERYBODY IS
COMFORTABLE WITH. THE
COMMISSION. OKAY THAT WAS A
MOTION AS WELL CENTER BECAUSE
IT. OKAY AND AGAIN I'M
RECOMMENDING IT ALL RIGHT- ON
THIS BILL- SEEING OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO SOME
REMEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE- I'LL
USE THAT AS MY CLOTHES WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS HAD VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS THAT I
THINK THAT WE KNOW THAT. WE'RE
YOU KNOW ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED
TO ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS
BUT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE- NO TENANT SHOULD HAVE
TO. JUMP THROUGH HOOPS TO GET A
DANGEROUS APARTMENT- INSPECTED
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WHERE THE MOTION BY SENATOR
CORTEZ HE AND WE WILL CALL. THE
ROLL. THIS IS A SEMI BILL EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES. SENATOR
WIENER. BY WINTER I BET IT'S
NO. IT'S NO COPYRIGHT. COURTESY
WELL I'VE GOTTA SAY I'VE
ACQUIRED. A CHORE BOOK. MUCH OF
A DOUBT THAT IN. SKINNER
SKINNER I AM BURKE HI NUMBER
FIVE WITH CASKEY. FOUR TO ONE
THEY WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS BOBBY FORGET
OUR NEXT SET OF JUST AS A
REMINDER FOR ANYONE WHO WAS NOT
ON THE LINE AT THE BEGINNING.
ITEM TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN AT TEN FORTY THREE HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE HAIR PULLED
FROM THE AGENDA TODAY AND WILL
BE RESET FOR NEXT WEEK'S
HEARING TEST SO NO ONE IS
WAITING AROUND FOR A GIRL THE
STOPPING HER TODAY. WHEN X. GO
TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN MAYBE TEN
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BALIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME
AND YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MR MEMBERS WE'RE ALL
AWARE OF THE MASSIVE SHORTAGE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
STATE. ONE OF THE LESSER KNOWN
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE ISSUE IS
THE EXPIRATION OF SO CALLED.
AFFORDABILITY COVENANTS. WHEN
CALIFORNIA HAD REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS THAT RECEIVE FUNDING FROM
THE AGENCY. WERE REQUIRED TO
RECORD CONFIDENCEON THE
PROPERTY THAT WE GUARANTEE.
THAT THOSE UNITS WOULD REMAIN
AFFORDABLE AT BELOW MARKET
RATES. FOR THIRTY YEARS AND IN
SOME INSTANCES FIFTY YEARS. AS
TIME PASSES MANY OF THOSE
COVENANTS REACH THEIR TIME
LIMITS AND EXPIRE. AS THOSE
TIME LIMITS EXPIRE. THE UNIT
MAY THEN BE LEASED AT MARKET
RATE. AS HE CAN- RESETS THE
MARKET RATE THAT IS ONE LESS
AFFORDABLE UNIT THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO A LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. MAYBE TEN TWENTY
NINE SIMPLY ASK THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. TO ADD
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS. TO THEIR LIST OF
PRIORITIES FOR ALLOCATION OF
STATE FUNDING. IT'S MUCH EASIER
TO SAVE A UNIT FROM CONVERTED
TO MARKET RATE THAN TO BUILD A
BRAND NEW UNIT. THIS IS A
SIMPLE YET IMPORTANT STEP TO
MAINTAINING. CALIFORNIA'S
SCARCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION ON THE
BILL. YEAH WITH ME ON THE PHONE
TODAY OUR MAYOR SANTIAGO HONEY
THE MAYOR OF FOSTER CITY. AND
BARBARA GORE SAID HE RETIRED
RESIDENT OF FOSTER'S. LANDING
BARBER SAID HE IS- A RESIDENT
OF- FOSTER CITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A FAMILY MEMBER WILL NOW
GO TO THE LEAD WHEN IT SAYS
WILL START MAYOR HANI. FOLLOWED
BY BARBARA CASSETTI YOU'LL EACH
HAVE. TWO MINUTES WELCOME TO
THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME. HI
MR SURE CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MR SHARED MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS SANJAY GANDHI I'M THE
MAYOR OF FOSTER CITY I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THINKING OF SOMETHING
THE MEMO AND PREPARING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION BOSSIDY
HAD A VERY ACTIVE REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND WHAT SUCCESSFUL IN
CREATING HUNDREDS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THEIR- CITIES
PRODUCT THAT OUR EFFORTS HAVE
RESULTED IN FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE AFFORDABLE UNITS IN
A CITY OF ABOUT. THIRTEEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
TOTAL UNITS. WHEN THE FOSTERS
LANDING APARTMENT DEVELOPMENT
WAS BUILT IN THE MID NINETEEN
EIGHTIES IT INCLUDED SEVENTY
FOUR BELOW MARKET RATE RENTAL
UNITS IN THE FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY UNIT DEVELOPMENT. THE
PMR RESTRICTIONS WERE DUE TO
EXPIRE BEGINNING WITH FIFTY
UNITS WELL LAST YEAR ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY. THE REMAINING TWENTY
FOUR UNITS- ART BASED EXPIRED
VARIOUS TIMES WITH THE FINAL
TEN UNITS EXPIRING ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. BUT THE TRICKIEST ARE
SET TO EXPIRE LAST YEAR THE
CITY IN THE PROPERTY OWNER
AGREED TO EXTEND THE PORTABLE
BRANCH TO THE BASE TO THESE
TENANTS UNTIL DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
CITY ALLOCATED MONEY FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO PAY THE CITY
SHARE OF THIS PROGRAM. HOWEVER
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR THE
RESIDENTS OF FOSTER'S LANDING
WILL SEE THEIR RENTAL FROM A
TYPICAL FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
ABOUT THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH. NOW FOSTER
CITY HAS TAKEN SEVERAL STEPS TO
ASSIST THE TENANTS OF FOSTER'S
LANDING AT ALL RESIDENTS OF OUR
CITY TO LIVE IN. OR LOOKING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE FORMER
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
AREA WILL HAVE LITTLE TURNOVER
AND LONG WEIGHTLESS.
PRESERVATION OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT IN
ADDRESSING THE EXISTING HOUSING
CRISIS. WE WILL NEVER GET AHEAD
OF THE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IF WE'RE UNABLE TO
PRESERVE AND MAINTAIN UNITS.
ALREADY HAVE. THE COUNCIL
EXPRESSED ITS STEADFAST
COMMITMENT TO RESIDENTS IN THE
DRESSING THE NEED FOR MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN OUR
CITY. THAT INSPIRED DIRECTION
TO STOP. TO SEE THE STATE
PARTNERSHIP. MAYBE TEN TWENTY
NOW WOULD BETTER POSITION THE
CITY TO. FOR FUNDS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. TO TRY AND SECURE A
LONG TERM FUNDING SOURCE FOR
FOSTER'S LANDING. ON A THANK
YOU FOR PROVIDING ME WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
EFFORTS WE HAVE MADE IN BOSTON.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING NEEDS OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. THANK YOU.
THIS GROCERY. THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS BARBARA THIRTY AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MALL ENTRANCE. THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD PREVENT HOMELESSNESS AND
FOSTER CITY I'VE BEEN A
RESIDENT OF POPULATED FOR FOUR
YEARS I READ IT IN A POCKET THE
BROKER. FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS.
RECCA MARK INFLATED I WAS NO
ABLE TO PAY MY RENT. THIS LED
ME TO THE BELOW MARKET RATE
APARTMENTS. I WAS FORTUNATE TO
MOVE INTO POPULARITY AFTER
BEING ON WAITLIST FOR SIX YEARS.
MANY OF THE RESIDENTS ARE
SENIORS LIKE MYSELF LIVING ON
ONE INCOME. THERE ARE OTHER
FAMILIES WITH MEMBERS WITH
DISABILITIES AND SINGLE PARENT
FAMILIES. AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE BELOW
MARKET RATE RESIDENTS. AS A
DOCTOR MAYOR THE HUNDREDS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE A NOTICE OF THE
CABINET THE POSSIBLY DO WITH
GOING TO EXPIRE. I DON'T HAVE
MOVIE GOING TO MARKEDLY
INCREASE IN IRAN AS MUCH AS
THREE HUNDRED PERCENT. IF YOU
START MIGRATED IN HIGHER PRICES
FOUND THEMSELVES IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC. AN ALREADY
TROUBLING SITUATION. THAT FOR
MANY OF THE RESIDENTS. THANKS
FOR THE CITY OF MARKETING AND
AS THE CORPORATION. INTO AN
AGREEMENT TO ALLOW US TO SAVE.
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR HOWEVER.
EVEN WITH THE ADDITION YOUR-
LOOK VERY GOOD. CURRENTLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSE UNITS THE AREA
I WILL. ANYWHERE FIVE TO TEN
YEAR AND IT RESIDENTS A BUDGET
WE WERE QUITE ON THE LOTUS
HERE'S ONE OF THE CITY'S. I
WOULD BE LOW MARKET RATE UNITS
IN FACT IT DIDN'T HAPPEN AT THE
TIME. OF THEIR CULTURE TRIPLED
OUR COMMITMENT. AT THE RESULT
MOVING INTO ANOTHER AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COMPLEX. IS NOT AN
OPTION WE ARE FORTUNATE THAT
THE TEMPE HAS BEEN ATTEMPTED
KIDNAPPING EXACTLY PLACEMENT
BUT NOW I KIND OF BRING IT OUT
AND MANY OF THE PEOPLE HAVE
NOWHERE TO CALL HOME. EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY NINE WILL PROVIDE
FOR THE BLACK PARTICIPANTS ARE
HAVING DEVELOPERS ANOTHER TOOL
TO ENSURE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STAYS AFFORDABLE AND THE FULL
EFFECT SO MANY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. I THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AND. ON
THURSDAY I. THINK IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT OF TESTIMONY THE GALA
AS NO ONE. WE'LL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. I SEE NO ONE. WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT OF PHONE TESTIMONY AND
PLEASE SIMPLY SAY YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE FACT
OF YOUR SUPPORT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT THE PORT OF A. B. TEN TWENTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO IN Q. ONE NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE WINNER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN
CLAMP HOPPER THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO REPORT OF A B. TEN TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU. BEFORE WE OPEN
LINE FORTY EIGHT AND A REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. TEN TWENTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU. MR CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SHARING INVOLVED WITH THE
RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY THE REDWOOD
CITY CROWN AT BELMONT AND
CARLSBAD AND STRONG. AND AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
HERE. TRAFFIC WE WILL NOW GO
TO. OPPOSITION IF ANY TO MAYBE
TEN TWENTY NINE. WE HAVE NO
OFFICIAL OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED
AS OR ANYONE IN THE GALLERY I
SEE NO ONE. IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
I SEE NO ONE. I'M NOT A
MODERATOR WE PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINES. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF THE B. TEN TWENTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF MAYBE TEN TWENTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
OPPOSING ABOUT. GRAY WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OTHER ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON THIS BILL. WITH THE BILL
MOSHE BY SENATOR CORTEZ THE
CENTER CENTER. IDO HAVE A
QUESTION I SUPPORT THE BILL BUT
AN- SO I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THE- I'M COMPLETELY AWARE OF
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE MANY OF
THE- LONG TERM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- MUCH IN THE LONG TERM
IN MANY OF OUR CITIES. HAS
THESE. YEARS SPECIFIC YOUR
COVENANTS I THINK I FORGET WHAT
THE ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY UNITS.
SKIS ME IN BERKELEY FOR EXAMPLE
WE COULD POTENTIALLY LOSE BUT
UNDER THIS IT GIVES- PRIORITY
IF THE CITY DESIGNATED SELF AS
DESCRIBED THEN THEY WOULD HAVE
PRIORITY IN TERMS OF SOME OF
THE FUNDING PROGRAMS AT THE
STATE- HAS AVAILABLE THAT IS
THE STRETCH MY FIRST QUESTION
IS THAT ACCURATE AND THEN. IS
THE REMEDY- IS THE ONLY ISRAEL
ONLY REMEDY THAT JURISDICTIONS
HAVE TO MAKE THESE UNITS LONGER
TERM AFFORDABLE IS TO PURCHASE
THEM. SO. SO THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER- YES THERE ARE SOME
THIRTY PLUS THOUSAND UNITS-
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS THAT
ARE THREATENED TO USE TO FLIP
INTO MARKET RATE IS SIMPLY ADDS
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS TO- THE LIST OF- ELEMENTS
THAT BC HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT-
CONSIDERS IN TERMS OF FINDING-
TO THE KEYS CAN CAN WE CREATE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP FIND-
THE GAP. THAT WILL EXIST- BUT
CANDIDLY- BUT THE FUNDING IS TO
FOR THE JURISDICTION TO
PURCHASE THE HOUSING RIGHT
BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY REAL
REMEDY TAKEN TO MAKE IT
AFFORDABLE SAID. STATION BUT
WHAT HAPPENS. RIGHT OKAY THREE
YEAH RIGHT. THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
CENTER SCANNER- IT SAID WHILE
IT IS SAYS IS POINT OUT YOU
KNOW THIS IS- IN MOST CASES NOT
ALL LESS EXPENSIVE IF YOU CAN
GET THE AGREEMENT WITH TO
PURCHASE THEM- COMPARED TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION. IT'S STILL THIS
IS A THIS IS DAUNTING SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE I WISH THAT
WE HAD AN ADDITIONAL REMEDY
THAT WE COULD PROVIDE TO ENSURE
THAT THESE UNITS STAY PORTABLE
BUT I DO VERY MUCH SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS. AND THEN SENATOR IF I
MAY- I'LL BE THE FIRST TO TELL
YOU THAT THIS IS A MODEST.
APPROACH TO A VERY BIG PROBLEM
THAT EXISTS SO I WOULD WELCOME-
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS TO SEE
IF THERE ARE SOME ADDITIONAL.
FINANCIAL OPTIONS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE ARE STATE OF THE
AFFORDABLE COLUMN- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT GOING FOR BUT THIS AT
LEAST PUTS UP. A BASELINE AND-
INTO THE LAW THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT I USE OF STATE
HOUSING FUNDS IN TERMS OF
PRESERVATION BUT LOOK FOR ALL
PUBLIC LOOKING FOR OTHER
REMEDIES- WITH YOU ON THIS.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SOME REMEMBER
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF AND
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
CONVERSATION AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR A VOTE. GREAT AND I
AM RECOMMENDING AND I- AND
THANK YOUR SUMMER NUMBER. THE
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE AND
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
A SUMMARY BILL TEN TWENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER I'D BATES NOT VOTING
IT'S NOT VOTING COPYRIGHT.
COPYRIGHT COURTESY COURTESY I'M
ACQUIRE. A CHORE BOOK. THE
TROUBLED NOTE SCANNER BY
SKINNER HI AMBER HI AMBER WHAT
KASKY. FIVE TO ONE. WE'LL PUT
OUT A CALL FOR ACTION MEMBERS
THANK YOU SOMEONE NUMBER WE
HAVE OUR FINAL AUTHOR HERE
TODAY SO MEMBERS BLOOM WHO WILL
BE PRESENTING TWO BILLS WE'LL
START WITH ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE.
WELCOME SUMMER NUMBER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SEEMS LIKE I
JUST SAW YOU. LAST NIGHT. YEAH
AND TO A SENATOR'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU AS WELL I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR HELPING WITH
THE AMENDMENTS ON EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE AND I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THEM AS COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE WILL INVALIDATE
DENSITY RESTRICTIONS AND
PRIVATE COVENANTS THAT DO NOT
ALIGN WITH LOCAL ZONING. UNTIL
THE MID TWENTIETH CENTURY
RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
WERE USED AS A TOOL TO
SEGREGATE. AND REDLINED
NEIGHBORHOODS. COURT DECISIONS
AND THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
HAVE MADE RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS UNENFORCEABLE
THANKFULLY AND- BUT THESE
COVENANTS OFTEN CONTAIN OTHER
VESTIGES OF THIS DISCRIMINATION
SUCH AS LIMITS ON THE NUMBER
AND SIZE OF UNITS THAT CAN BE
BUILT ON A PARCEL. THE DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS ALSO CONFLICT WITH
LOCAL ZONING CODES THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND DESPITE THEIR
DISCRIMINATORY ORIGIN IN CLEAR
CONFLICT WITH LOCAL ZONING.
THESE RESTRICTIONS REMAIN
ENFORCEABLE AGAINST AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER.
SO THREATS OF LAWSUITS OVER THE
RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO GET TITLE
INSURANCE COVERAGE AND FUNDING
FROM LENDERS IN THESE
SITUATIONS THE TIME AND EXPENSE
NEEDED TO REMOVE THE COVENANTS
DETERRED DEVELOPERS FROM
ACQUIRING AND DEVELOPING ON
THESE OTHERWISE. IDEAL PROJECT
SITES. EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
WILL ENSURE THAT THESE PRIVATE
CONFIDENCE CANNOT BE USED TO
CURTAIL MUCH NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE MEASURE CLARIFIES
THAT DENSITY RESTRICTIONS IN
PRIVATE COVENANTS ARE
UNENFORCEABLE AGAINST A 1100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE WILL
ENSURE THAT WE BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE UNITS WHILE
PRESERVING AND STRENGTHENING
LOCAL CONTROL. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORTR. BRANDON
PAYETTE WITH PUBLIC COUNSEL AND
HAY SEUSS HERNANDEZ WITH THE
COMMUNITY CORPORATION OF SANTA
MONICA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SOME REMEMBER WHEN I GO TO A
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES BRANDON.
AND HIS IS HERNANDEZ YOU MAY
PROCEED YOU'LL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
BRANDON PATH I'M A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH PUBLIC COUNCIL
THE NATION'S LARGEST PRO BONO
LAW FIRM. ON THE FIRST THANK
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR CAREFUL ATTENTION TO
THE HOUSING CRISIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. ON ITS FACE EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE CENTS FOR A
SIMPLE PROPOSITION AT A
PROPERTY OWNER WANTS TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THE
PROPERTY THAT THEY OWN THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BUILD AS MUCH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THEIR
PROPERTY AS THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION WILL PERMIT. AN
OPENLY RACIST LAND DEVELOPERS
FROM THE NINETEEN TWENTIES AND
THIRTIES SHOULD HAVE NO SAY IN
THIS DECISION. MANY PEOPLE ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE HISTORY OF
RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
THAT WERE DESIGNED TO PROHIBIT
PEOPLE OF COLOR FROM READING AN
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOODS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEGACY OF
THOSE RACIST RESTRICTIONS LIVES
ON. RECORDED RESTRICTIONS THAT
LIMIT DEVELOPMENT CHRONIC GIVEN
PARTIAL TO A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
RESIDENTIAL UNITS. OR TO A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF BUILDINGS ARE
OFTEN TREATED AS ENFORCEABLE
TODAY. EVEN IF THOSE
RESTRICTIONS ARE MORE LIMITING
THE APPLICABLES OWNING CODE BY
MANY SCHOOLS. EVEN IF THOSE
RESTRICTIONS ARE CONTAINED IN
THE SAME DOCUMENT. AS
EXPLICITLY RACIST RESTRICTIONS
ON WHO MAY LIVE THERE. EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE WOULD MAKE THE
PRIVATE DENSITY RESTRICTIONS IN
RECORDED COVENANTS
UNENFORCEABLE AGAINST 1100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS. THEREBY REMOVING
A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE IN NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT HAVE THIS HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED THEM. JUST IKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MODIFY
EXPLICITLY RACIST RESTRICTIONS
CURRENTLY CODIFIED IN
CALIFORNIA LAW. EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE IMPLEMENT A NEAR
IDENTICAL PROCESS FROM
MODIFYING THESE PRIVATE DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS. IMPORTANTLY THE
BILL WOULD NOT MAKE NOR WOULD
IT REQUIRE ANY CHANGES TO LOCAL
ZONING CODES ON LAND USE RULES.
SIMPLY ALLOW A PROPERTY OWNER
TO BUILD AS MUCH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON A GIVEN PROPERTY AS
THE ZONING CODE WOULD ALLOW.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL DOES NOT
DO AWAY WITH RESTRICTIVE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE OF THE
PROPERTY NOT RELATED TO THE
SITE. LOCATION OR NUMBER OF
RESIDENTIAL IMPROVEMENTS THAT
CAN BE BUILT THERE WOULD REMAIN
FULLY ENFORCEABLE AND EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE EXPLICITLY
ALLOWS A LOCAL COMMUNITY. TO
RETAIN ITS CHARACTER BY
ENFORCING DESIGN AESTHETIC
RESTRICTIONS OR BY IMPOSING
MAINTENANCE FEES TO KEEP COMMON
AREAS IN GOOD REPAIR.
IMPORTANTLY THE BILL HAS BEEN
CAREFULLY CRAFTED TO ENSURE
THAT LEGITIMATE CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS ENVIRONMENTAL
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS AND OTHER
IMPORTANT CONSERVATION MEASURES
THAT LIMIT DEVELOPMENT. REMAINS
WE HAVE A PUBLIC COUNSEL ON THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
ON EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE TO
CONTINUE THE PROCESS OF
RECTIFYING THE HARM OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY OF
RESIDENTIAL SEGREGATION. AND
DISCRIMINATORY. HOUSING
POLICIES. THANK YOU. AND THE
NEXT WINNERS CAN START. SURE HI
EVERYONE- GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE COUNCILMEMBERS BUT
THE NUMBERS RATHER THIS IS WHAT
HAS TO HAPPEN ON THAT I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
OF COMMUNITY CORPORATION OF
SANTA MONICA WE ARE A MID SIZED
NONPROFIT THAT HAS OPERATED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
AFFLUENT WEST SIDE OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FOR ALMOST FORTY
YEARS. I HAD TO START BY
THANKING ASSEMBLYMEMBER RICHARD
BLOOM PER CHILD FOR CHAMPION
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR MANY
YEARS HIS LEADERSHIP HAS
CREATED MANY POLICIES THAT MAKE
IT EASIER TO DO OUR WORK. AND
INCREASINGLY CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENT. HE RECORDED HERE
TODAY S A COLD SPONSOR OF AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE. BECAUSE
OF THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS WE BELIEVE. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SHARE WITH POLICY
MAKERS OBSTACLES WE FACE. IN
THE HOPES THEY CAN BE FIXED.
THE ISSUES RAISED BY A B.
SEVENTEEN. MY A. B. SEVEN
TWENTY ONE ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
PERPETRATE HISTORICAL
SEGREGATION OF NEIGHBORHOODS.
AS AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER I HAVE SEEN
RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS EXTREMELY
THE RACIAL PROVISION. ALONG
WITH ACCOMPANYING DENSITY
DESTRUCTION MULTIPLE TIMES
USUALLY I HAVE CHOSEN TO WALK
AWAY FROM THE NEWS ABOUT THE
BIKE BUT AFTER THE EVENTS. OF
THE PAST YEAR I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CHALLENGE THAT IT
WILL. TAKE AWAY THE POWER. AT
THE SECOND GUESSING THAT THE
COMPANY HAD LET. TO REMOVE SUCH
COVENANTS CAN COST A LOT OF
MONEY AND EXPAND THE COURT
PROCESS THE PROPERTY'S ALREADY
LONG OR DESIGNATED FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING BY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION WE BELIEVE. WE
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THAT- THAT PROCESS. IN MONDAY
BUT I MEAN WE ARE WORKING ON
CURRENTLY THE PROPERTY IS.
DESIGNATED MULTI FOUNDED BY THE
CITY. AND THE ONLY THING
STANDING IN THE WAY AND THE
PRIVATE ALL STANDING COVENANT
AMONG PROPERTY OWNERS IN THE
NINETEEN FORTY. EIGHT TO
PROHIBIT MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPMENTS. IT WILL PROVIDE
OVER A HUNDRED UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT HAS A NOBLE OUR
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY. THANKS TO
THE MANY COMPANIES RECORDED IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD. WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE OUR COSPONSORED
PUBLIC COUNSEL WHETHER SPLAINE
MORE ABOUT THE COVENANT AND HAS
WORKED VERY HARD. TO HELP US
THROUGH THIS PROCESS SO THAT WE
CAN. BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. WE CANNOT BEGIN TO
ADDRESS EXCLUSIONARY
NEIGHBORHOODS WITHOUT THE DRESS
IS SURE TO COME IN. AND USE THE
PARK BUT THEN THE BLOOM NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVENTEEN. SEVEN TWENTY
ONE AT A STEP TOWARD ENDING
THE- IRRATIONAL IT'S
PRACTICALLY THANK YOU FOR MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN I GO
TO- AS OTHER SUPPORTER OF.
PUBLIC COMMENT I SEE NO ONE IN
THE GALLERY GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. I SEE NO ONE THERE-
WILL OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT- OF FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE PLEASE SAY YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE FACT
OF YOUR SUPPORT. NOT A
MODERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE SIX IN Q. WITHOUT REPLY
NUMBER EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON IN
JAPANESE MARISSA HOW CAN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SEVEN TO ONE THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR THE VIOLENCE HERE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS YOU KNOW
ABOUT THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT. NINE
ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TODAY SHE IS THE
WOOD NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DEFINITELY CHECK THE LIVE
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT HOUSING AND SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE.
NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IF YOU ALREADY HAVE
YOUR CHAIR AND- I'M SORRY GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS WITH THE
DAY TO DAY OUT THEN ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC ADVOCATE. WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU- BEFORE WE
OPEN NINE SEVENTY THREE OF THE
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK PART OF
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MY SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU. ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TWENTY ONE OH TWO
DIFFERENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE OH TWO ONE OF THE
LINE IS NOW OPEN. AIRPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
WANTS TO PULL UP MY SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
YEAH DEFINITELY A LOT LATER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT
AT THE PARK. AND AT THIS TIME
WE DON'T HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
GREAT WELL GO TO OPPOSITION TO
AB. SEVEN TWENTY ONE. WE HAVE
NO LEADER OPPOSITION
IDENTIFIED. I SEE NO ONE IN THE
SENATE GALLERY WE'RE GOING TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. I SEE NO ONE
THERE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. BUT A MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE
LINE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIR MARK
FENSTER MAKER FOR THE CAR
CALIFORNIA. COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS NOT NOT POSITION BUT IN
A TWEENER POSITION WE HAD
RAISED A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL WHEN IT WAS
MOVING THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY.
BUT THOSE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
MATCHED BY MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS OR JUST WANT TO
THANK MR BLOOM AND STAFF AND
THE SPONSORS FOR ALL THE MANY
HOURS THEY SPENT WITH US. WHAT
DO THOSE CONCERNS AND PROTECT
IMPORTANT CONSERVATION
MEASURES. WE ARE PLEASED TO
MOVE TO NEUTRAL. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE OPPOSING WITHOUT.
GET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. C. NINE IS OUR MOTION
CENTER KELSEY YEAH I HAD A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR ON. I
SEE THE BAD STUFF THAT'S GOING
ON WITH THESE- PRIVATE
RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS AND WE
WANT TO WE WANT TO. OUTLAW
THEM- AND THE BILL SIMPLY SAYS
THAT THEY'RE UNENFORCEABLE. IF
THE IF THE PROPERTY IS
DEVELOPED AT A 100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THERE'S A FIFTY
FIVE YEAR DEED RESTRICTION. IF
WE WANT TO GET RID OF THE
RESTRICTED WOULDN'T IT BE MORE
INCLUSIVE EFFORT SAY THE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSAL IS 50%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR 40%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN ST IF
YOU IF YOU APPLY. THAT TYPE OF-
OF- MAKE THAT TYPE OF
APPLICATION THESE RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS GO AWAY. IF I IF I
THINK OF A VENDOR STAND THE
HARM THAT WE SEE IN THESE
RESTRICTED PRIVATE COVENANTS IS
SORT OF OUR DESIRABILITY TO
WANT TO BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. SOME RUMOR. WELL I
WISH THAT- THINGS WOULD BE SO
SIMPLE- THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
BILLS THAT ON ITS SURFACE-
LOOKS LIKE AN EASY SLAM DUNK
BUT IT RAISED OTHER ISSUES THAT
TOOK. MANY MANY HOURS OF
NEGOTIATION- HE BILL
PRIORITIZES 1100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IT CERTAINLY COULD BE
LEFT TO THE FUTURE BILL TOO- TO
EXPAND THAT- EVEN MARKET RATE
HOUSING BECAUSE THERE'S NO
REASON IN SOME OF THESE- AREAS
WHERE IT'S ZONED FOR MULTI
FAMILY. WHY ONE WOULDN'T TO-
NECESSARILY WANT TO BUILD THE
MARKET RATE HOUSING. BUT THE
PRIORITY HERE IS 1100%
AFFORDABL AND- IT WAS THE BILL
WAS BROUGHT TO US BY A SPONSOR.
WHO ONLY DOES 1100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND SO THAT'S THE WAY
THE REASON ADULT READS AWAIT US.
CENTER CARRIER THE ONLY MOVE
THE BILL. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
BY CENTER CALERO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- A
SUMMARY OF MY CLOTHES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- IT'S JARRING
TO- GREAT I READ A- A DEED FROM
MANY YEARS AGO- AS I DID A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WHEN I READ
THE DEED ON MY PARENTS HOME.
AND SEE RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS THERE WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY SEE IT AND CAN
PERSONALIZE IT THAT WAY YOU-
IT'S MUCH MORE. IT'S A MUCH
MORE DEEPLY HURT BUT ALSO
SPEAKS TO- WHERE WE ONCE WERE
AND HOW FAR WE'VE COME- AND YET
THIS BILL REMINDS US THAT THE
VESTIGES OF- OF THOSE DEED
RESTRICTIONS AND OF THAT.
DISCRIMINATION STILL EXISTS
TODAY AND THERE'S STILL THINGS
WE CAN DO TO REPAIR THE WORLD
THAT WE LIVE IN AND OUT WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I'VE
BEEN. TAKEN A LONG. TIME THANK
YOU SOMEONE NUMBER- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CAFIERO. I
WILL CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
BILL SEVEN TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
DEMAND AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATOR
WIENER OUR WINNER I'D BATES NO
BEDS NO COPYRIGHT HI COPYRIGHT-
CORTICES. COURTESY I'M ACQUIRE.
THE TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE NO
SCANNER. BY SKINNER I REMEMBER
ALL RIGHT NUMBER I. WOULD
CASKEY HI THE CASKET I. SIX TO
TWO CLICK ON CALL SOME NUMBERS
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER WILL
NOW GO TO- YOUR SECOND BILL AND
OUR FINAL BILL PRESENTATION OF
THE DAY ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT- WHICH I.
LOOKS VERY FAMILIAR TO ME SINCE
I OFFERED THIS LAST YEAR AND IT
DIED AT THE STROKE OF MIDNIGHT
ON AUGUST THIRTY FIRST SO
SUMMER THANK YOU FOR- FOR
BRINGING THIS BACK AND YOU MAY
PRESENT YOU HAVE YET A LITTLE
MORE REPAIR WORK MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU- AND I'D LIKE TO
START WITH ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AND AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
ON A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT.
AND OF COURSE THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE THE-
CURRENTLY IF A JURISDICTION
DOES NOT ADOPT THE HOUSING
ELEMENT BY THE STATUTORY
DEADLINE AND IT MUST. ADOPT A
REVISED HOUSING ELEMENT. EVERY
FOUR YEARS RATHER THAN EVERY
EIGHT. THIS PENALTY FOR NON
COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING ELEMENT
ADOPTION DEADLINES HAS PROVEN
INEFFECTIVE. AND LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. FOR
EXAMPLE UNDER CURRENT LAW A
CITY OR COUNTY CAN ADOPT A
LEGALLY DEFICIENT HOUSING
ELEMENT. ALMOST FOUR MONTHS
AFTER THE STATUTORY DEADLINE.
WITH NO CONSEQUENCES. IN FACT
SOME JURISDICTIONS HAVE ADOPTED
FAULTY DRAFT ELEMENTS BY THE
DEADLINE. KNOWING THAT THE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES AND
REVISIONS WERE NECESSARY TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW. JUST TO
AVOID A PENALTY OF HAVING TO
REVISE THE ELEMENT IN FOUR
YEARS. IN SOME JURISDICTIONS
THE ADOPTED ELEMENT WAS NOT
REVISED TO CORRECT THE LEGAL
DEFICIENCIES FOR MORE THAN
TWELVE MONTHS AFTER THE
DEADLINE. AND IN SOME CASES NOT
FOR YEARS. FOR INSTANCE ONE
CITY ADOPTED A DRAFT ELEMENT IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND FOUND. DID NOT
MEET STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS THE
CITY TOOK NO FURTHER ACTION TO
REMEDY THE LEGAL DEFICIENCIES
UNTIL TWENTY NINETEEN FIVE
YEARS AFTER THE CITY WAS
ORIGINALLY SUPPOSED TO ADOPT
ITS ELEMENT. AB THIRTEEN NINETY
EIGHT WOULD ADDRESS THESE
PROBLEMS BY CLARIFYING THE LAW
TO REQUIRE ADOPTION OF AN H. C.
D. APPROVED HOUSING ELEMENT BY
THE STATUTORY DEADLINE. THE
BILL ELIMINATES THE FOUR YEAR
PENALTY AND INSTEAD PROVIDES
THAT FAILURE TO TALK TO ADOPT
ONE TIME. OBLIGATES THE
JURISDICTION TO COMPLETE ANY
NECESSARY RESULTS WITHIN ONE
YEAR RATHER THAN IN THE THREE
YEARS THAT'S A LOT FOR
JURISDICTIONS THAT ADOPT ON
TIME. MY WITNESS TODAY IS BRIAN
AUGUSTA WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT.
THANKS THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
SERVICE. TO THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND MEMBERS-THANK YOU MR BLOOM
FOR OFFERING US INTO THE CHAIR
FOR GETTING IT ALMOST TO THE
FINISH LINE LAST YEAR- THE
AUTHOR HAS EXPLAINED THAT THE
GOAL OF THE BILL VERY WELL SO I
WILL JUST USE THIS TIME TO URGE
THE COMMITTEE. BERNARD VOTE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY.
THANK YOU IS THERE SUPPORT OF
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE GALLERY I
SEE NO ONE THERE. ROOM ONE
TWELVE- NO ONE IS THERE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
SUPPORT OF PUBLIC COMMENT. ON
THIS BILL. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. ONE THREE NINE EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. M. LINE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
HERE NUMBERS IN REGARDS TO
BLOCKCHAIN CENTRUM ON POVERTY
AND SUPPORT. AND IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK AT THE PORT OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE SHOWING
SUPPORT. OKAY WE'LL- NOW THAT
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPONENTS IDENTIFIED. I SEE NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY. I SEE NO
ONE EVER ONE TWELVE PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE IS
NO ONE OPPOSING ABOUT. CABLE
RAN BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- IS.
THERE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THIS BILL.
MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER
SAYING NO OTHER BIKES UP- SOME
REMEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU FOR OUR COMBINED EFFORTS-
ON THIS BILL MISTER CHAIRMAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS A
SUMMARY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WINNER.
WINNER I'D BATES NO IT'S NO
COPYRIGHT. ZERO COURTESY. FOR
TENNESSEE I AM ACQUIRE. A
TROUBLE NO MORE TROUBLED NELL
SKINNER BY SCANNER I- BURKE HI
AMBER I WOULD CASKEY. WITH
HEALTHCARE HI. SO TWO HEY WE'LL
PUT ON CALL FOR A MEMBER SOME
NUMBER THANK YOU I SAID I
COMPLETES OUR BILL
PRESENTATIONS- YES DO WE KNOW
IF IT'S POST. RIGHT WHAT DOES
OPEN THE ROLE SO WE CAN GET
EVERYONE ELSE OUT OF HERE AND
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING ON CALL
FOR CENTER REQUIRE. MODELS WILL
START AT THE BEGINNING ITEM
ONE- EIGHTY TWO FIFTEEN PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE OF NUMBERS.
THIS IS A SUMMARY BILL TO
FIFTEEN BY SOME I REMEMBER TO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR CAFIERO.
COPRIGHT UPLOADING REQUIRE
SCANNER ALL RIGHT SCANNER I
WOULD CASKEY HI WHAT KASKY ARE.
FIVE TO TWO THEY WILL PUT THAT
ON CALL- ITEM NUMBER. TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT ONE SIX. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT ONE SIX BY FAMILY
MEMBER TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
SENATOR CAFIERO. SCANNER BY
SKINNER I WOULD CASKEY. BY THE
CASKET BY. FIVE TO TWO. OKAY-
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL- WILL
NOW DO THIS CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEMS THREE FOUR AND SEVEN.
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE OF
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATOR CAFIERO HI ZERO I
REQUIRE. SKINNER FIVE SCANNER
WHICH IS KEY HI WHAT KASKY II.
EIGHT ZERO WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR. ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR CAFIERO HI. I'M
ACQUIRE. SKINNER BY SCANNER I
WOULD KILL SKI WITH HUSKY HI
EIGHT TWO ZERO THEY WILL PUT ON
CALL- WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
ONE. THIS CALL MAY HAVE SOME
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WARD THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CAFIERO HI. COPYRIGHT I
AM THE CHOIR. SCANNER HI
SKINNER I WOULD CASKEY HI THE
CASKET HI EIGHT ZERO. OKAY FOR
IT NINE. EIGHT NINE REMEMBER-
THE A. THIRTY EIGHT WHEN YOU
PUT IT WAS IT HAD A NUMBER
EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE AND
NUMBERS. SEVEN WHAT. AND WE'RE
PUTTING WE'RE PUTTING IT BEFORE
ANYONE BACK ON COSTS. I DON'T.
SEVEN SEVEN WITH A- NOW I'M
GOING TO- DELIVERING WATER FROM
THIS. OKAY GOT IT. SORRY TO
ORDER ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE OF NUMBERS IT'S
NEEDED FOR EVERYBODY- TO SIMPLY
NEVER COULD NASSER. EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE MY SUMMER
BLOOM THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. REQUIRE. SIXTY TWO.
OKAY WE'LL PUT IT BACK ON
BECAUSE- ON I'M SORRY ON AB.
OKAY CALL MISTER CGUIRE AGAIN
AN ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE. SOME OF THE SEVEN
TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM MCGUIRE. HI MCGUIRE HI.
SEVENTY TWO OKAY THE BILLS OUT.
ONE ITEM NUMBER NINE A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT. SOME OF
THE THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM THE MTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE. BY REQUIRE A
SEVENTY TWO THE BILL AS ADULTS.
IN THE- ZERO CALIFORNIA DID HE
SAY. MAYBE I AM HE'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH A NUMBER
OF COPIES. WE'RE GONNA CALL
THIS A GUY WHO. OKAY ITEM
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE BECAUSE THE
NUMBERS. I AM. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN SENATOR
CAFIERO. ZERO FIVE MCGUIRE
REQUIRE NOT VOTING WHAT KASKY
WHAT KASKY ARE SIX TO ONE.
EVERYONE HAS VOTED THAT BILLS
OUT. I AM ELEVEN EIGHTY TEN
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MOHAN. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MALEN
SENATOR MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I WOULD
CASKEY. CASKEY HI SEVEN ONE
EIGHT OF THOSE ADULTS ON WHOSE
CINEMA WIRE IF YOU- ITEM TWELVE
IS COLD IT'S GONNA BE HER NEXT
WEEK- WE'LL GO BACK- TO CLOSE
OUT THIS SEVEN ITEMS ARE OPEN
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY TWO
FIFTEEN PLEASE CALL UP SOME
NUMBERS. THAT'S A LITTLE TOO
FIFTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER TWO
SEVEN ACQUIRE. NOT VOTING BUT
WE'RE NOT BETTING FIVE TO TWO.
THE BILL'S HOUSE- A NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT ONE SIX ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT ONE SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE A SIX TO TWO
THE BILLS OUT BY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS THREE FOUR AND
SEVEN. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SOME OF THEM REQUIRE I REQUIRE
HI NINE ZERO. I'M WELLS FARGO
MY APOLOGIES TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS APPROVED ITEM
NUMBER FIVE ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR.
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON SENATOR
REQUIRE. NOT VOTING. EIGHT TWO
ZERO- OKAY THAT BILL AS ADULTS-
ITEM NUMBER. SIX EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY ONE. SOME OF THE FOUR
NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WAR SENATOR MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI
NINE ZERO. THE BILLS OUT-
BENEFITS OPEN EVERY NOW COVERED
IN CLOSE OUT EVERYTHING. OKAY
WE'VE NOW HEARD I'M GOING TO
CLOSE OUT ALL ITEMS I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY ON THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
WE ARE- GERMS.